[Musique]
Virginie Jon bonsoir bon après-midi
d'ailleurs exceptionnellement est-ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter succintement
bonjour Virginie Jon j'ai 51 ans je suis
maman juriste de formation j'ai grandi
dans le sud de la France à Frégus j'ai
fait des études de droit à Nice jusqu'à
un desss je voulais rentrer dans la
police et j'ai découvert ce que c'était
des informations lors de ces cours
puisqu'on avait un module qui nous
ouvrait l'esprit sur comment manier
l'information les informations après je
me suis installée en Alsace en 2000 à
l'époque j'avais un fiancé je me suis
marié après en alsas j'ai travaillé de
longues années dans un dans une grande
compagnie d'assurance il y a 40 ans
j'ai pris ma carte au rassemblement
national à l'époque c'était le Front
National et puis après ouverture à des
mandat j'ai été élu conseiller régional
en 2016 dans la région grandest et après
j'ai eu l'opportunité d'être présidente
du groupe j'avais en charge 35 élus et à
l'issue de ce mandat j'ai été repéré
aussi par mon parti et ils m'ont
installé à Bruxelles entre Bruxelles et
Strasbourg j'ai obtenu ce ce mandat de
député européen en 2019 et j'étais
reconduite en 2024 pour un second mandat
de députés
européens aujourd'hui on va parler Union
européenne on va écouter vos arguments
on va écouter s'il y a de la corruption
ou si on pense qu'il y a de la
corruption ou s'il y a des des faisceaux
d'indice pour parler
comme juristes ou les policiers aussi ou
qui indiquerait de la corruption tout
d'abord et puis peut-être aussi pass
sanitaire j qui vous sont chers ou
première question pourquoi la police
d'ailleurs parce que j'avais des un
idéal de justice
et quand au cours des au cours des
comment dire des diplômes que
j'obtenais avocat c'était aussi
intéressant mais je préférais m'engager
dans la sécurité parce que c'est aussi
un point important pour moi l'ordre
social l'ordre publ et j'ai fait un
stage d'un mois dans un commissariat à
Nice et j'ai pu faire tous les services
et j'ai de du service judiciaire de la
police judiciaire on a fait aussi du
terrain on on a fait des descentes alors
c'était marrant j'étais étudiante à
l'époque donc je faisais des descentes
dans des bars et je rencontrais des
collègues étudiants et euh au cours de
de ce stage je me suis rendue compte
qu'en tant que femme ça allait être
difficile pour moi parce que je suis
très sensible et euh plusieurs fois j'ai
été euh invitée à à essayer de résoudre
des troubles de voisinage et euh c'est
vrai que j'étais pas imperméable aux
arguments de des gens et le soir j'avais
vraiment une charge émotionnelle et je
me suis dit c'est pas pour moi c'est
c'est trop j'étais peut-être sans doute
trop jeune à l'époque et du coup B j'ai
laissé tomber cette voix mais quand même
j'avais à cœur de rester dans
l'information et desésinations parce que
cette ce cours était très intéressant
parce qu'il nous avait démontré comment
le gouvernement pouvait manipuler
l'information on avait eu un cours avec
à l'époque c'était un commandant des
armées c'était le secpa c'était un
service d'information et il nous a
expliqué pour la guerre d'irac comment
ils avaient pu en tout cas amener les
gens à accepter la guerre en Irak avec
des images avec des titres et j'avais
trouvé ça très intéressant et puis c'est
à ce moment-là donc j'ai laissé tomber
la police parce que en plus j'avais dû
rejoindre à l'époque mon fiancé et
maintenant mon ex-mari en Alsace et
comme il faut faire un concours j'aurais
je n'aurais pas pu le le suivre en
Alsace donc j'ai fait ce choix et euh et
donc je suis repartie à zéro et je me
suis plutôt tranquillement je suis
rentrée dans les assurances alors à
cette époque mais quand même cette
ouverture d'esprit m'a permis avec
notamment cette ouverture de comment
lire les informations je me suis
intéressé un peu de loin à la politique
voilà c'est comme ça que je commençais à
regarder les débats politiques mais
j'avais pas la même lecture que mes
collègues ou autes d'O d'où mon intérêt
après à suivre des partis politiques qui
étaient qui étaient ostracisés dont à
l'époque le Front
national comment ça se passe à
Bruxelles ça se passe bien les débats
sont houleux pas houleux c'est calme on
arrive à échanger il y a de la
transparence alors le travail est très
intéressant puis moi je peux voir
maintenant une évolution entre mon
premier mandat et le second premier
mandat 2019 nous sommes un parti qui
s'appelle groupe identité démocratie on
est entre le 5e et le 6e groupe donc on
est une force politique
mais pas très entendu voilà on est
encore mis de côté et puis là nous
grande nouveauté on devient la 3e force
politique au sein de ce Parlement
européen puisqu'on a créé ce nouveau
groupe qui s'appelle Le Patriote pour
l'Europe avec notamment une personnalité
de puissante qui s'appelle Victor Orban
euh ce n'est pas rien puis en plus euh
depuis 2019 il y a une dynamique euh qui
a amené beaucoup de partis patriotes à
la victoire c'est-à-dire
qu'effectivement euh nos partenaires de
laalga euh sont rentrés au gouvernement
avec euh le madame Meloni euh gervil d'
aujourd'hui bah c'est lui qui est qui a
les les les reennes du pays euh en
Autriche encore quelques temps pareil
donc si vous voulez il y a une are
dynamique qui s'est mise en place et du
coup on voit bien
qu'au sein de cette
institution il y a une crainte il y a
une crainte de la part de des autres
groupes politiques d'où le fait qu'ils
aient mis en place un cordon sanitaire
alors déjà précédent mandat ouais sûr
vous m'autorisez bien sûr je pourrais
parler des heures comme ça sans
m'arrêter parce que il y a a une
particularité au Parlement européen
c'est que vos débats se limitent entre
une minute et 2 minutes connaissez le
proverbe le simple et le court c'est le
passeport direct pour le slogan
idéologique pur ouais quelle est la
différence je vous ai coupé mais je vous
pose ma question quelle est la
différence entre nationaliste et
patriote
c'est un peu la même chose seulement
euh seulement ça c'est la même chose
pour vous oui pour moi c'est la même
chose je veux dire il y a pas de gros
mot que ça soit d'un côté comme de
l'autre on défend une nation on défend
un drapeau on défend une identité on
défend une
culture mais seulement c'est vrai que
pour certains médias c'est devenu un
gros mot mais sur le fond en plus ce
n'est pas c'est c'est peut-être le terme
moderne on va dire de la même énergie
c'est-àdire on défend une couleur on
défend une tradition on défend une
identité et finalement ce qui nous
rejoint c'est queon est des patriotes
dans dans l'âme dans le sens où on veut
défendre nos intérêts qui sont
supérieurs à nous donc pour nous c'est
effectivement la France au sein de cette
union européenne et et et j'avoue euh
parce que je suis novice quand même en
politique hein on peut pas dire que j'ai
autant d'expérience que certains qui
sont là depuis des années notamment au
Parlement européen on avait des vieux
cassiques de de des républicains comme
Monsieur brisortefeu euh moi celui qui
aime les tableaux non mais je crois
qu'ils aiment tous les tableaux il y en
a plusieurs qui aiment les tableaux mais
euh ce que j'ai remarqué c'est que la
France hein nous ici voilà on est
patriote on aime la France on pense
qu'on est une puissance et bien je peux
vous assurer que au Parlement européen
elle est ignoré la France et même le le
pire c'est précédent mandat quand
Monsieur Emmanuel
Macron a eu la présidence du Conseil
pendant 6
mois très honnêtement dans les couloirs
ils étaient moqués ils venaient en
retard déjà aux réunion ils n'étaient
pas entendus on en connait d'aoutes qui
qui vont pas du tout au réunion et on
n'aime pas les bruit couloir mais mais
mais mais il mais mais la grande
différence c'est que ils gouvernent la
France et ils avaient la présidence du
conseil donc ils avaient une image et
surtout des intérêts à défendre lors de
cette présidence du conseil et moi ce
que j'ai vu c'est que la voix de la
France est ignorée euh on est
aujourd'hui soit à l'époque 72 députés
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on en a 76
députés qui représentent la France sur
un total de combien sur 720 donc pour
défendre je vous donne un exemple pour
défendre le siège à Strasbourg il faut
se battre et en plus la particularité
qu'il y a c'est que sur des sujets où
c'est le bien commun qu'on devrait
défendre et bien il y a plus personne
pour en tout cas c'est de s'organiser et
faire entendre notre voix donc c'est
vrai qu' ce que moi me choque
aujourd'hui c'est que la France n'existe
pas la France n'existe pas au sein du
Parlement européen je parle pas pour
nous notre patriotes puisque nous sommes
un autre groupe où effectivement nous
vivons et avec cette dynamique qui est
quand même présente avec à chaque
élection il y a une nouvelle vague
patriote qui arrive donc effectivement
nous arrivons à vivre et à nous faire
entendre contrairement à le pays la
France où Emmanuel Macron perd de plus
en plus de de d' et le dernier exemple
je finis avec ça c'est quand même
l'arrivée de Stéphane séjourné qui voilà
Stéphane séjourné qui a été recasé à la
Commission à la tête de la commission
une grande expérience ah ben ça ça
n'engage que vous hein mais moi le peu
que j'ai vu d'expérience qu'il a eu au
sein du Parlement européen puisqu'il a
il était chef de la délégation des
macroniste au Parlement moi je vous
donne une anecdote c'est le le dossier
que j'ai suivi premier mandat c'est le
dans la commission spéciale covid où
j'étais membre à la à l'issue de cette
commission qui a rédigé une espèce de
recommandations pour prévenir des
prochaines pandémies où on a remis en où
on a mis comment dire sur le sur le
podium la stratégie vaccinale pour pour
les prochaines pandémies on n jamais
d'ailleurs le mot effet secondaire n'a
jamais été mentionné dans ce rapport et
moi je l'ai je l'ai dénoncé j'ai déposé
plein d'amendements et juste pour finir
c'est dire que sur ce dossier qui était
soit-disant
la victoire une des meilleures gestions
de l'Union européenne le jour du vote le
jour du vote Stéphane séjourné était
présent mais il a pas pris part au vote
ouais ça c'est et ça je me suis dit
c'est quand même étrange parce que le
chef de délégation qui prend pas part au
vote alors qu'il était présent alors
j'ai j'ai d'autres noms hein il était
peut-être malade en retard non non il
était là il était à son pupitre il était
à son pupitre il était à son pupitre il
y a trois boutons un blanc c'est c'est
abstention un rouge bah c'est contre et
vert c'est pour mais il était pas le
seul dans ce cas-là François Xavier bami
aussi était là il a pas pris part au
vote et c'est intéressant C cette cette
ce vote parce que vous voyez un
éclatement des positions de vote même le
PPE qui est vous savez le PPE c'est le
parti de Madame Van derlayen d'accord
qui est où il y a le plus de d'allemand
c'est la CDU donc c'est son parti vous
avez aussi l'ER qui figure dans ce parti
éclate des votes même parmi les
Allemands euh une autre anecdote celle
qui avait donc ce rapport qui tenait ce
rapport de la commission celle qui a
rédigé ces recommandations d'ailleurs
j'avais dit c'est une blague au début
c'était 10 pages j'ai l'impression que
c'était écrit par le laboratoire Pfizer
parce que c'était l'ude au vaccin et bon
après tout le monde a déposé moi j'en ai
posé je sais plus à l'époque 300
amendements enfin tout le monde a déposé
plein d'amendements parce qu'il fallait
aménager le texte tout étaéit refusé
malheureusement mais bon au moins il y a
les écrits et puis nous à la fin moi
j'ai refusé ce ce rapport c'estàd que
c'est bien écrit on on on ne veut pas de
ce rapport et même elle dans les
couloirs donc c'est une dame je peux pas
dire son nom parce que voilà elle est
encore présente aujourd'hui donc une
Espagnole qui avait ce rapport et elle
me dit
Virginie je sais le travail que tu fais
parce que quand Mme une reconnaissance
dans les couleurs du travail que j'ai
fait elle me dit tu sais parce que tu
toi là comme ça quand même he tu sais
j'ai pas fait vacciner mes
enfant je dis B ouais mais tu as pas
fait vacciner ces enfants mais tu
imposes aux autres parents de te faire
faire vacciner les enfants mais ces
enfants avaient peut-être des
contreindications
c'était pas c'était pas l'objet de de du
message mais voyez l'hppocrisie et c'est
vrai fait vacciné vous si je peux
m'autoriser à vous demander un dé j'ai
déjà dit moi je suis vaccinée de tout de
tous les vaccin classique qui pour moi
ont pas eu de problème jusqu'à
aujourd'hui par contre celui-là non j'ai
refusé c'était trop violent puis moi je
suis je sais pas je vous vous dites
qu'il faut tout sourcer et c'est
important et moi j'ais besoin d'avoir
les sources Tangi pour me dire celui-là
ce vaccin qui sort en moins de 9 mois il
y aura pas de problème je je vous l'ai
dit je travaille dans les assurances il
y a une question de responsabilité donc
de ce fait moi qu'est-ce qu'on dit on
dit Virginie tu vas te faire vacciner je
fais ok pas de problème puis en plus je
suis maman comme j'ai dit aussi j'ai une
responsabilité vis-à-vis de de ma fille
et donc je je veux savoir si demain il y
a un problème puisquil est sorti en
moins de 9 mois qui va payer qui si en
cas de
problème et puis en plus moi j'avais une
maladie autoimmune une autoimmune
purpura trombopénique idiopathique j'ai
interrogé une l'association parce que
c'est des maladies autoimmune donc
maladie rare donc j'ai interrogé cette
association qui qui m'a dit qu'elle ne
savait pas donc pour moi c'est pas une
réponse et puis après il eu quelques il
y a eu quelques faits divers que qui
m'ont vraiment touché c'est-à-dire la la
mort de cette adolescente Sonia en
septembre 2020 puis avant Maxime Beltra
qui qui sont décédés et je me suis mis à
place de ses parents je me suis dit mais
comment vivre avec ça et c'est à partir
de ce moment que j'ai pris le dossier en
main je me suis dit c'est pas possible
c'est vrai que tout le monde pas pasugé
est-ce que c'est est-ce qu'il faut
prendre pas position pas c'est vrai tous
les hommes politiques à cette époque-là
était pas très courageux j'ai envie de
le dire et je me suis dit ben moi c'est
pas comme ça que je travaille euh j'ai
travaillé dans les assurances je veux
savoir euh pourquoi d'abord qu'on
m'explique pourquoi quel est l'intérêt
d'eux et en cas de problème qui paye
j'avais pas donc j'avais pas ces
réponses donc je suis allée fouiner dans
les contrats j'ai vu que les contrats
étaient à 90 % cachés donc alors là
c'est pas possible quand vous avez dit
est-ce qu'il y a des problèmes de
transparence bah ouais clairement notre
notre rôle notre premier rôle en tant
que député c'est quoi on doit contrôler
le budget c'est notre travail de
contrôler ce qu'ils font c'est je suis
un peu le gardefous on est les
gardesfous de la commission ils peuvent
pas faire n'importe quoi donc je suis
allé voir les contrats et en fait il
avit rien à voir puisque on voyait rien
tout était caché
et euh et puis après ben j'ai écouté un
petit peu la télévision même si je la
regarde pas trop parce que on na'a pas
le temps et puis je trouve que c'est
toujours la même la plupart c'est c'est
le même narratif donc ça ça me convenait
pas et puis toute la journée vous voyez
la même la même messe c'était la même
messe partout et puis quand il y a eu
cette chasse aux sorcières contre
professeur raou professeur Peron dès
qu'un médecin sortait du cadre il se
faisait dégommés donc là non plus ça m'a
pas plu puis puis toutes ces mesures
l'hyperticides qui avaient pas de sens
euh
les policiers on leur imposait pas la
vaccination mais les gendarmes oui les
alors le pire ça a été les discothèques
interdites mais pas les bordels un
moment donné tu te dis mais il y a c'est
rationnel pas rationnel on vaccine
pourquoi en fait il y a pas de bordel en
France
euh a priori si quand même en tout cas
caché enfin moi j'y suis pas allé he
j'avoue mais c'est mais bon voilà on
sait que quand par contre il y a des
bordels peut-être en Belgique non pareil
je je ne sais pas euh j'avoue que que
c'est pas mes mes mes comment dire mes
mes idées de sortie
privilégié mais oui parce qu'apparemment
il y en aurait mais je je je n'ai pas
conna enfin en tout cas moi je sais pas
où et je je n'y suis jamais aller mais
voilà en tout cas tout t tous ces
événements ont fait que je me suis
intéressé au sujet après bordel en
Allemagne ça c'est sûr ouais ben en tout
cas en tout cas ils avent la
possibilité d'y aller pendant le covid
qui est pour moi un non sens parce que
si on veut protéger la population d'un
virus c'est
pas d'un côté et pas de l'autre c'estd
c'est soit on a vraiment peur on veut
vraiment protéger les gens d'un virus et
on met tout tout en place ou alors on se
fout ou alors se fout de nous et pour
moi c'était la deuxième option on s'est
bien foutu de notre gueule c'était des
bordels avec des mesures barrières il y
avait des vitres ah ben voilà donc c'est
c'est votre témoignage très bien
Témo c'est noté d'accord je sais pas bon
je vous emmènerai faire un tour si vous
voulez on fera les routes de Bruxelles y
c'est important en fait de regarder dans
les trèsfonds et dans les bas fonds de
chaque société pour comprendre l'énergie
exactement comprendre mais pas besoin
d'aller dans les bordels hein pour
comprendre cette mauvaise énergie hein
je je vous assure à Bruxelles nous on
peut rester dans le Parlement et dans la
commission he comme vous avez lancé le
sujet de la
pandémie on va continuer avant de passer
à la corruption les dossiers qui fait
quoi comment qui signe quoi comment qui
reçoit des SMS et qui donne pas ces SMS
qui comment
la pandémie vous voyez des États
occidentaux par exemple la France le
pays de pasteur et j'ens passaient des
meilleurs commencer à s'agiter commencer
à paniquer commencer à mettre une chape
de plomb pour un coronavirus il y a des
coronavirus tous les ans qui peuvent
toucher les pays de différentes sortes
mais là il voit que c'est quand même dur
vous les voyez réagir votre première
pensée
c'est ils savent que c'est sorti dans la
BO que c'est un accident industriel ù
ils ont vu une veille qui a montré que
il y avait un taux de mortalité que ça
touchait les vieux et que comme le les
services de santé étaient un peu
compliqués vous connaissez les services
de santé en France ouais si on allait
commencer à trier les patients sur le
trottoir politiquement parlant c'était
une mise à mort pour les partis
politiques et peut-être pour les
patients
euh vous avez vu les les les maisons de
retraite
ances et on en voit d'autres votre
première pensée quand vous voyez un état
paniqué ça a été
quoi j'ai eu le covid au tout début moi
je l'ai eu je savais pas ce que je
savais pas d'ailleurs que ça s'appelait
le covid moi c'était une grippe je l'ai
eu janvier en revenant d' d'une
croisière je pense que je l'ai eu sur
une croisière décembre 2019 CIT où la
croisière c'était une croisière entre
Venise j'ai fait toute la la Croatie
j'ai fait toute la tique en fait
magnifique magnifique et je reviens et
donc début janvier 2020 grippe d'enfer 4
jours au lit je pouvais plus je me suis
dit d'ailleurs je vais mourir
honnêtement c'est ce que je me suis dit
parce que je impossible de bouger du lit
ce qui m'a sauvé parce que bon voilà je
pouvais pas j'ai même pas la force
d'appeler le médecin je suis asthmatique
j'ai des chats je mais je je suis
allergique au chats mais j'adore mes
chats donc j'ai quand même l'avantoline
et c'est laavantoline donc je me suis
pris laavantol toute la semaine et ça va
je me suis je je m'en suis sortie je je
veux je vais voir alors attention à
l'automédication hein ah ouais maison
voilà vous savez vous prenez ce que vous
voulez voilà vous pas envie de mourir
quand même donc vous essayez tout ce que
vous avez sous le bras donc moi j'avais
deipran j'avais et j'avais donc
l'avantoline parce qu'effectivement
j'arrivais plus à respirer donc est-ce
que c'était ça est-ce que je faisais une
crise d'assme en même temps bon en tout
cas j'ai utilisé ce moyen je m'en suis
sorti je dis à mes collègues au travail
j'étais un conseiller régional à
l'époque je punaise C cette année cette
grippe wouh si tu peux te faire vacciner
parce que je vaccin pour pour la grippe
pourquoi pas contre la grippe pourquoi
pas je lui dis si tu as tes tes
grands-parents tout ça je te conseille
parce que moi là 4 jours j'ai cru que
passé d'ailleurs j'avais arrosé toutes
mes plantes avant je m'étais dit si on
me retrouve la semaine prochaine au
moins j'ai nourri les plantes et les
chats bon voilà vos chats les onont
attrapé ou pas non non et ni ma fille
zéro bref je passe cet épisode et puis
vous avez fait un test anticorps pour
savoir si c'était le covid ou pas on
savait pas janvier c'était trop tard
c'était c'était j'ai chopé ça au mois de
janvier donc moi je savais pas c'est
commencé à sortir au mois de on avait
des doutes là comment ça certains
commençai à dire oui il y a un truc qui
qui revient du jeux olympiques il y
avait une équipe de militaire mais on
savait pas je crois qu'on a commencé à
dire vraiment covid un mois après et
c'est là que j'ai fait le rapprochement
d'ailleurs ma collè m'aelé dit ah tu
crois je j'en sais rien parce que bon
voilà en plus pour moi c'était le temps
était déjà passé et donc j'ai vu
effectivement la mise en place de la
gestion de crise en plus j'étais encore
conseil régional j'étais présidentE de
groupe donc mise en place du télétravail
on faisait tout à distance pe tous les
jours on commenca il commençait à mettre
en place l'histoire du masque pas du
masque donc j'observais ça voilà de loin
et
puis j'avais pas d'avis en fait pour
l'instant je m'étais dit ok moi je l'ai
vécu comme ça
euh mais mais le déclencheur de la où là
j'ai vu que c'était pas cohérent c'est
la mise en place des mesures c'estd que
les parlementaires n'étaient pas obligés
de se faire vacciner al on en est pas
encore là on en est pas encore là on est
juste sur l'histoire des masques on a la
région et là j'ai compris que c'était
politique j'ai monsieur c'était l'époque
Monsieur rotner qui d'un coup voulait
récupérer tous les tous les stocks
d'Alsace pour les remettre le DF le DF
tout reprenait tout même des vieux
masques et tout et puis il faisait sa
pub en fait c'est là que je me suis dit
tu peux pas faire ta pub là-dessus tu
peux pas faire ta comme politique
là-dessus tu veux sauver des gens ou pas
et là je me suis dit ça ça m'a mais ça
je me suis dit il y a il y a un problème
et le deuxième c'était B il y avait une
réalité c'est-à-dire que vous alliez
dans les cliniques privées il y avait de
la place on pouvit mettre les gens là à
l'époque mais oui mais bon on veut
sauver les gens ou pas on peut pas
laisser les gens à la maison on leur dit
il faut se confiner il faut tout arrêter
les restaurateurs un moment donné on les
a on les a complètement fermé on on peut
pas un moment donné dire que c'est la
fin du monde vous allez tous mourir on
arrête tout et on laisse crever les gens
chez eux et on et et on les on les
transfère pas dans la clinique et ce qui
a fait là à un moment donné le doute
c'est quand j'ai vu des hélicoptères des
hôpitaux mis en place vous savez avec
détente de fortune devant devant les
hôpitaux publics mais moi j'avais des
collègues qui travaillent en clinique
qui me disent mais attends Virginie je
comprends pas nous on a c'est vide chez
nous c'est vide pourquoi il transfère
pas les malades chez nous dans les
cliniques donc là voilà je commençais à
me dire alors je je suis pas complotiste
mais je me suis dit il y a quand même un
problème au niveau de la gestion et et
puis après bon je pense que tout a
démontré que voilà c'était c'était des
des c'était politique on a utilisé des
cabinets de conseil privé pardon oui et
et on a vu le résultat vous êtes maamnim
avec moi vous me rendez le
micro je me dis Virginie 45 ans ouais
pleine force de l'âge se chope un covid
reste 4 jours plombé au litouis passé a
fait ses a déposé ses dernières volontés
pour sécher ses plantes vertes bon il y
a des populations à risque en France
ouais les obèses les asthmatiques les
diabétiques les vieux les très
vieux les
sénateurs c'est dangereux pour on a un
système de santé qui qui se vaoutre on a
sans doute des services de renseignement
qui sont posé la question si ça sortait
de Wan et est-ce que ça avait été
militarisé il préfèrent gérer le truc on
leur accorde le bénéfice du doute mais
ensuite la question que je vous pose
c'est quand on vous dit bon vous pouvez
prendre un café mais assis ah bah oui
mais oui et ce genre de peties mesures
ouais quand on les a vu désinfecter la
plage c'est qu'on pouvait se plage
dynamique voilà les les plages
dynamiques dynamiques c'est fallait
marcher sur la plage pas rester plus de
10 minutes voustes pas dit vous êtes pas
dit bon alors il faut pas rester il faut
pas rester assis il désinfecte les
plages c'est parce que il y a un un taux
de rémanence du moins le virus reste
avec selon le support plus ou moins 5
jours 6 jours 7 jours ça dépend du
support il panique il désinfecte les
gens à la sortie de l'avion à coup de de
pulvérisateur les Chinois l'ont fait
c'est ça créit un minimum mais c'était
pour faire peur surtout et puis ça c'est
votre interprétation moi c'est pour mon
interprétation un pour faire peur aux
gens certains l'ont utilisé pour
aussi comment dire prendre aussi la
casquette du Sauveur voyez je fais
quelque chose pour vous à can c'est
Monsieur Lisnard qui a fait nettoyer les
plages pour enfin franchement c'est
quand on quand on y pense on a dépensé
des millions la mais parce qu'en fait je
sais pas ça se fixe sur le grain de
sable et que le il y a du vent il y a du
enfin franchement il pensait avec du
recul il y a du vent ça reste pas c'est
statique après je sais plus scientifique
l' expliqué le virus de toute façon
après il se il est volatile donc
aéroporté aéroporté voilà moi je suis
pas scientifique mais j'écoute quand
même ce qu'ils disent et c'est
intéressant et il faut les écouter c'est
d'ailleurs pour cette raison que je les
ai invité au par Parlement parce que je
voulais avoir le leur avis en terme
d'audition ou en terme consultation non
non de de de de consultation parce que
pour avoir ob tenir des auditions auprès
de la commission ou en tout cas avec le
Parlement c'est c'est comment dire c'est
voter donc comme on sait que c'est pas
très démocratique bah chaque fois qu'on
présentait des experts ils étaient
refusés mais pour en revenir à votre
question
oui je pense que il y a une gestion des
crises qui a été menée un pour maintenir
une Chae de plomb à un moment donné
précis sur les gens parce queil y avait
un intérêt aussi politique moi je l'ai
vu comme ça notamment et sanitaire
peut-être
oui sanitaire mais est-ce qu'on a pas
utilisé cette crise pour pour finalement
contrôler politiquement à un moment
donné les gens est-ce que vous
m'autorisez à faire l'avocat du diable
oui bah bien sûr je vais vous demander
de vous mettre à la place d'Emmanuel
Macron
ouais et on va faire une expérience de
pensée vous et moi vous êtes Emmanuel
Macron vous
recevez le 31 décembre une petite alerte
de votre ambassadeur en Chine il y a
machin qui se balade là Macron il
appelle les services de renseignement ok
vous êtes sur le terrain qu'est-ce qui
se passe les services de renseignement
font remter exactement les mêmes infos
qu'on avait en direct c'està-dire
checkpoint analyse de l'eau hpitaux de
campagne quartier pvre fermé avec des
barres soudé devant les portes où il
s'estchanga uniquement un petit sac
plastique où il y avait qu'une seule
personne qui était autorisée à sortir et
à Wan il y a un labo P3 P4 ouais et il
se dit ou les chinois ils ont peut-être
militarisé une saloperie on a essayé de
récupérer les souches ADN des virus qui
qui ah bah ça a disparu bon vous mettez
à la place de Macron ou de quelqu'un
d'autre bien s il protège les Français
bien bien sûr mais alors si on veut
vraiment protéger et sauver des vies on
ferme pas des lits d'accord ça c'est
après ah non non c'était pendant non non
c'était pendant la crise il a fermé des
lis pendant la crise 1 c'est quoi vos
sources bah c'est les sources que là je
les ais pas mais c'est toutes les
sources publiques franchement vous
pouvez regarder là aujourd'hui encore je
sais même pas le nombre mais en tout cas
il y a eu des ils ont fermé des lits
pendant pendant la la la crise c'était
d'ailleurs une stratégie qui était mis
en pièce depuis depuis un moment où il y
avait une volonté de réduire les
dépenses alors peut-être ils ont pas
réduit 500 1000 mais on on réduit 500
mais ça s'est accéléré après la crise
covid moi j'entends ça bien sûr qu'il
faut protéger les Français mais alors on
donne les moyens au médecins c'est on
leur empêche pas de prescrire on leur
empêcher de prescrire c'est çarire quoi
et bien ce qu'on a toujours prescrit
pour lutter contre la grippe je veux
dire moi j'ai eu la grippe vous avez eu
sans doute la grippe on vous prescrit
des antibiotiques à un moment donné
c'est obligatoire les antibiotiques
c'est pas obligatoire mais un moment
donné quand au bout de 3 semaines vous
avez toujours votre grippe on vous
prescrit des médicaments et il y a eu C
cet hiver une très grosse grippe et
c'est à la fin tout le monde a eu ses
antibiotiques je dis pas que c'est la
clé miracle mais c'est une grippe virale
ah ben est-ce qu'on traite les virus
avec des
antibiotiques en tout cas moi quand j'ai
eu la grippe on m'a donné des
antibiotiques à un moment donné parce
que c'était la seule solution que le
médecin avait donc après chaque médecin
connaît mieux son patient et encore une
fois on veut protéger les Français donc
on laisse pour moi le premier premier
principe c'est de de faire confiance aux
services médical à nos médecins à
l'hôpital aux cliniques et on leur a
enlevé moi je trouve qu'on leur a enlevé
les moyens on leur enlevé cette liberté
il y a depuis des années des médecins
ont
toujours géré ces grippe et à ce
moment-là on leur a empêché et bien sûr
qu'il fallait prendre des décisions dans
l'urgence et ça je l'entends parce
qu'effectivement pendant pendant un mois
il y a eu un flottement sur ce que
c'était et comme moi je l'avais eu et
j'étais pas séparage donc j'avais un
regard un peu moins de
crainte mais c'est vrai j'étais en bonne
santé comme l'avait dit mais mais vous
avez vu ce que j'ai dit aussi c'est que
j'ai dit attention aux anciens j'ai pas
pensé aux autres qui avaient des
difficultés de de se faire vacciner
contre la grippe rappelez-vous les
premières vidéos des Américains qui
rapatrient les Américains de
Chine c'était alerte avec dustine
Hoffman ouis oui exactement les gens
étaient en Combin pris les cas les plus
graves ét en caiss son
pressurisé bon choc des images Emmanuel
Macron non c'était surtout agès buisin
qui mettait des petites affiches à 4at
au Charles de Gaulle c'était quand même
surréaliste non je vais vous demander de
prendre la défense deemmanuel Macron
pendant 2
minutes avec les éléments que je viens
de vous
citer pour pour pour comment
dire c'est difficile
euh parce que lui aussi à un moment
donné euh euh à la veille des élections
municipal il a pas pris des précautions
donc il était flou aussi sur sa gestion
de crise parce que à un moment donné il
va indiquer il va prendre des mesures
pour pour que les Français obtiennent
des masques et puis vous avez sa sa
porte-parole qui dit mais en fait compte
ça ne sert à rien euh jusqu'à laaveille
des municipales je crois qu'il était
sorti avec son épouse euh à l'Opéra hein
thre au théâtre donc à un moment donné
ça c'était pas cohérent hein c'est soit
soit effectivement c'est la fin du monde
il faut prendre toutes les précautions
on fait tout fermer on on impose aux
gens de rester chez eux mais après en
parallèle on n pas ce type de de de de
décalage par rapport au message et à
l'action on va parevenir sur toutes leur
bourde de leur qui a ça cré énormément
de défiance par rapport à la science
d'ailleurs par que les gens les gens
sontin d'être bêtes contrairement à ce
qu'une partie de la politique par partis
politiques peuvent penser ils ont quand
même
déteché un petit peu d'incohérence donc
ça a créé énormément de défiance on va
par parce qu'on a aussi empêché les gens
de penser qu'il avaient peut-être des
questions à poser et c'est ça aussi la
problématique qui a eu dans cette crise
et c'est pour ça aujourd'hui qu'il y a
un autre problème c'est maintenant les
gens n'ont plus confiance du tout aux
politiques vaccinales et pour ça aussi
et donc et donc de ce fait il y a
aujourd'hui une crise de confiance euh
au travers de de cette gestion qui a en
plus divisé les gens entre rappelez-vous
les vaccinés non vaccinés il fallait les
emmerder pas les emmerder et puis moi je
le vois encore aujourd'hui c'est un
sujet qui qui a qui a marqué les gens à
vie parce queà ce moment-là il y a des
gens m qui n'étaient pas favorabl à
notre mouvement ils se sont réveillés
ils ont eu le troisième œil ils ont
compris qu'on les prenait pour des
imbéciles ils ont compris que finalement
euh ce qui était dit à la télé toute la
journée n'était pas vrai et ça c'est un
c'est pour moi un comme moi d'ailleurs
je j'ai j'ai pris ce dossier à cœur et
je l'ai pris de de d'ici je l'ai pas
pris de la tête je l'ai pris du ventre
c'estàdire que c'est là que ça s'est
passé je me suis dit c'est plus fort que
moi et je pense qu'on est beaucoup à à
avoir eu ce ce sentiment que là c'est
allé trop loin c'estàd que s'ils sont
capables de faire ça euh et bien c'est
le début de du totalitarisme j'ai envie
de dire et il fallait pas l'accepter je
sais qu'une grande partie là s'est
réveillé à ce moment-là des gens
effectivement moi je l'ai vu dans jour
je faisais mes courses euh en Alsace
donc euh j'ai quelqu'un qui m'a
poursuivi dans les rayons euh pour me
féliciter et pleurer dans mes bras parce
que elle m'a dit à ce moment-là à ce
moment-là madame vous m'avez sauvé alors
moi je j'étais très touchée par ça puis
je l'avais pas vu comme ça mais il y a
eu à ce moment-là beaucoup de de de gens
on fait tellement confiance au
gouvernement on fait tellement confiance
euh au poli politique et là il se sont
rendu compte qu'ils ont
été doublés qu'ils ont été trahis et ça
a fait un il y a eu un basculement à
partir de ce moment-là et ces gens-là
bah ils se voilà c'est des gens
maintenant qui qui s'intéressent à la
politique qui aussi bah voilà même si
ils étaient pas ils me le disent qu'
étaient pas forcément pour mon parti
bien ça les a amené à à reconsidérer
leur point de
vue quand vous vous rappelez on avait
quand même des médecins qui venit
s'exprimer nous expliquer qu'il fallait
vacciner quand vous avez vu au fur à
mesure au fil des des semaines s grainer
le l' le taux d'affaiblissement de
de comment je vais formuler ça on nous a
dit faites-vous vacciner c'est pour
sauver mémé parce que quand vous êtes
vacciné vous transmettez plus et puis
après on nous a dit bon vous êtes
vacciné mais vous êtes quand même
peut-être porteur sain faites gaffe
quand même à m'aimer
et au fur à mesure des semaines le
vaccin alors que ce soit chez Pierre
Paul jaacques
enco au départ c'était 100 % 90 % 95 %
80 60 30 alors 30 je sais pas si c'est
descendu jusqu'en bas mais le le le le
taux de protection
[Musique]
baissait ça ça vous a évoqué quoi
c'était ça a conforté votre sentiment
c'était ce qui m'a conforté dans ce
sentiment c'est qu'en même temps j'ai
j'étais membre de la commission spéciale
covid et dans cette commission on avait
l'opportunité d'interroger tous les
laboratoires et puis comme dit moi voilà
je suivais de loin ce qui se passait en
France mais en même temps j'étais dans
les contrats donc j'essayis de
comprendre un peu la dynamique de la
mise en place de la stratégie vaccinale
qui est très importante parce que
c'était c'était lié en fait premièrement
quand vous dites transparence tout à
l'heure m'a demandé s'il y a des
problèmes de transparence premier
contrat cursul van der Len cont
contuctualise c'est avec kururvac qui
connaît kururvac kururvac c'est une
boîte allemande ce qui ce qui s'est
passé c'est que elle l'a fait elle
l'avait même pas euhelle de marché non
non il y avait pas c'estàd qu'elle lui a
donné elle a donné 80 millions d'euros à
cette boîte donc où vous regardez
aujourd'hui il y a les les les
partenaires c'est la l'Allemagne il y a
même Bill Gates dedans alors et alors
c'est intéressant si si pourquoi je
reviens là-dessus parce que c'était au
tout début c'était et surtout ils ont
pas euh ils ont ils ont laissé tomber
l'affaire mais par contre les 80
millions d'euros ils les ont conservés
ça c'est la première chose qui m'a qui
qui était importante et puis dans cette
commission spéciale covid on a commencé
à découvrir plein de de de
problématiques notamment l'audition où
on avait demandé à ce que monsieur bourl
vienne c'est laboratoire Pfizer
laboratoire Pfizer c'est lui qui avait
contractualisé avec Madame vanerlayen
par SMS et donc donc on a demandé à
aussi l'entendre puisqu'on avait entendu
kururvac on avait entendu moderna tous
étaient venus tous ils sont venus sauf
Bourla Bourla Albert Bourla donc donc
PDG Pfizer plus gros contrat passé par
la commission au total c'est 4,2
milliards de doses que l'Europe a
commandé auprès de ses laboratoires dont
35 milliards d'euros parce qu'au total
c'est 71 milliards d'euros au total 4,2
milliards de doses pour 71 milliards de
contrats donc 35 milliards pour Pfizer
plus gros contat était peut-être malade
son chien avait peut-être non il était à
Davos la veille donc il était pas malade
non non quoné il a peut-être attrapé le
covid en étant à Davos non non il va
peut-être mais en tout cas il a il a
envoyé cette fameuse Jenine small donc
il a envoyé quelqu'un il a envoyé
quelqu'un sa représentante et est pas
actrice non ça c'est pas elle ça c'est
pour le le l'étude l'an 7 ah non je suis
hein ça c'est pour l'tud l'anette non
non c'est pas elle donc en fait cette
Jenine small elle vient représenter
Albert Bourla et la ce ce qu'on avait
fait c'était avec les autres députés on
était une petite team on était trois qu
mais hyper peti équipe très AC de
différents pays bon effectivement je
pens à Michel Rivasi même si elle était
pas dans ce groupe là mais elle
travaillait avec nous feu madame Rivasi
et vraiment j'ai une grosse pensée pour
elle décéder le 29 novembre 2023 on
aurait dû la recevoir elle nous suivait
sur Twitter mais paix à son âme paix à
son âme et c'était un choc à l'époque et
ça reste toujours un choc parce que
parce que voilà c'est c'était quelqu'un
d'admirable qui a fait un super travail
et qui nous manque parce que chez les
ver il y a plus personne qui repris le
flambau et euh et donc on fait cette
audition avec cette janitm on avait tout
préparé chacun nos questions pour qu'on
puisse être efficace pour qu'on répète
pas la même question donc Rober Rous qui
était un député des Pays-Bas dans un
autre groupe lui il avait dit je je vais
les attaquer sur le passe vaccinal parce
qu'effectivement pour lui c'était son
cheval de bataille pass vaccinal passe
sanitaire nous empêchait d'aller partout
il fallait justifieré de son statut
vaccinal moi j'avais dit écoute je
prends les effets secondaires parce que
je veux savoir où çaen est est-ce ils
ont pris est-ce qu'ils ont ils vont
prendre en charge euh ou il vont mettre
en place un fond d'indemnisation pour
les effets indésirables des Conz
l'assurance voilà donc moi j'étais parti
là-dessus et euh et donc Rob demande à
janit small ok euh vous nous dites que
euh euh le vaccin protège mais est-ce
que vous avez fait un test et là alors
là elle répond ben non en plus elleelle
prend pour des imbéciles en plus ben non
forcément on n' pas fait cette cette
étude pour savoir si finalement on a
testé euh avant la mise en place du
vaccin que ça empêchait la transmission
ça c'est combien de temps après c'est
quel vers quel mois euh je cense c'est
2022 c'est 2022 ça doit être octobre
novembre
2022 et euh et là ben c'est le buzz là
là en fait on prend cette phrase là et
là c'est ça part ça part jusqu'aux
États-Unis c'est dire qu'à partir de ce
moment là tout tombe et là on voit sa
tête parce qu'elle a pas réalisé et nous
on se dit ben merci merci on a bien
bossé on était content et là à partir de
là ben c'était terminé le le narratif il
prenait plus et c'est intéressant parce
que c'est à partir de là qu'encore plus
euh
euh la Commission a en off elle a
négocié alors en off ça veut dire à H8
clos euh comme ils ont vu ils arrivaient
pas àourguer les doses c'estut dire ils
ont commandé 4,2 milliards de doses je
rappelle on est 445 millions de d'euros
non de doses 4,2 millions de doses pour
450 millions de citoyens européens donc
10 doses par personne la dose Pfizer
c'était 20 € et nous ce qu'on a appris
lors de ces auditions à H clos donc il
fallait protéger pizer c'était pas pour
nous protéger nous hein pour protéger
Pfizer c'était de renégocier la dose
puisque après cette audition c'est vrai
que bah le narratif prenait plus il y
avait une demande encore moins qu'avant
de de de vaccin covid je crois qu'on
était à l'époque à la 4e dose au début
de la 4e dose et donc ça a pas pris du
tout ah I clou peut-être pour protéger
le secret industriel non c'était pour
protéger juste une chose parce que c'est
tellement gros c'est tellement énorme
c'est votre interprétation bah parce
qu'on a posé j'ai posé toutes ces
questions d'ailleurs je devrais même pas
en parler mais j'attends qu'il m'attaque
il y a pas de problème euh c'est pour ça
que je vous pose la question ah oui ben
je vous répond
qu'effectivement ça nengage que vous
comme dis la télé c'est çaoui de toute
façon il y a prescription maintenant ça
ça plus de 2 ans et puis le papier que
vous signez il vous font signer papier
une décharge il y a pas de date il y a
il y a rien il y a juste ma signature
pour dire oui je je m'engage à ne pas
parler de ce qui s'est dit dans la
réunion un moment donné la transparence
c'est aussi important je c'est aussi de
ma responsabilité de dire ce qui s'est
passé enfin je peux pour moi c'est pas
possible de ne pas dire que de 20 dos de
20 € la dose Pfizer c'est dire le secret
le secret de l'industrie c'est quoi de
de peut-être dire ce qu'il y a dans la
dose mais pas le prix le cet argent
c'est c'est notre argent c'est pas il
tombe pas de il tombe pas de de nulle
part c'est l'argent des contribuables
mais les 20 € c'était que pour les
Français ou pour tout le monde 20 € la
dose pour c'est un contrat d'achat qui a
été négocié par la commission donc
chaque étatmembre qui voulait
s'approvisionner avait un accès à cette
commande à 20 € la dose pour l'Europe et
donc annulation de la dose c'està-dire
on passe plus commande c'était ça qui
était dans à négocier et bien on la
passe à 10 balles à 10 € donc je
t'annule la dose donc ça veut dire tu
m'envoie pas la dose mais je te donne 10
€. voyez un peu l'arnaque mais c'est pas
une arnaque si vous avez fait une
commande faut un peu payer quand alors
j'ai envie de dire pas de problème mais
pas de problème on a des bons juristes
ou pas des bons juristes au sein de
cette commission on n' pas des clauses
de révoyure pas avec cette ses juristes
normalement c'était pour encadrer une
crise une pandémie donc on sait toujours
qu'une crise c'est temporaire donc ce
qui veut dire qu'on doit pouvoir avoir
une clause de revoyure dans le contrat
vous voyez donc c'est ça moi qui m'a
aussi choqué de voir dans ces contrats
où je me suis dit bon moi la petite
juriste des assurances j'arrive
là-dedans je dis mais qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce contrat qu'est-ce que c'est
que ce contrat où on peut pas réviser un
contrat qui nous engage et qui engage
surtout de l'argent public vous voyez il
y a pas eu de il y a une équip de
négociation j'ai regardé la dernière
fois la seule je regarde très rarement
la télévision l'émission de de Madame
Lucé qui avait fait vous savez
cette Élise Luc voyez tellement je
regarde tellement peu mais bon bref
je regarde cette émission et on apprend
effectivement que c'est l'équipe de
négociation euh qui n'a pas fait son
travail en fait puisqu'elles ont pas
demandé à mettre des clauses de revoyure
à à indiquer que le terme de crise on
doit bien définir ce que c'est une crise
une crise temporaire liée à une pandémie
X et qui et qui amène à une
renégociation des contrats et quand moi
j'avais posé à l'époque à c'était
l'agence ERA qui s'occupait de la la
gestion de ces contrats je dis euh mais
pourquoi on remet pas en question ces
contrats pourquoi on prend pas un are
alors si on n' pas les juristes dans la
commission pourquoi on prend pas un
cabinet d'avocat pour remettre en
question ce contrat ah nonz des fausir
d'ine
brokovic merci je ouais c'est gentil
parce qu'elle est jolie Julia Roberts
mais euh et là il me dit mais non pour
l'image on peut pas pour l'image on peut
pas ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on
doit payer Pfizer jusqu'en 2027 on leur
donne 10 € sans avoir la dose pour des
questions d'image donc ils oublient enc
encore une fois que cet argent c'est pas
le leur c'est c'est ce des Français ce
des Italiens c'est c'est c'est notre
argent et ça c cet exemple je vais vous
en donner un autre mais mettez-vous à la
place de l'industriel qui a acheté des
machines des
frigidesre à place d' petitte souris ou
des des des qui a engagé des
techniciennes des des laborantines qui a
engagé tout
ça il faut payer bah ils ont eu pas
slovide ça a été ils ont eu pas SLOV ils
ont vendu chez je sais pas
combien c'est pas votre problème ça non
effectivement et en plus c'est pas notre
problème ils arrivent toujours de façon
à refourguer le leur médicaments ou
autres dans d'autres États et puis
encore une fois l'intérêt moi je vous le
dis je vous trouve très dur face à eux
je me fais l'avocat du diable bah ils
sont pas à plaindre la première chose
que que Bourla a fait le soir de la la
mise sur le marché par l'Emma la va vite
l'Emma c'est l'agence de médicament
européen d'ailleurs je vais revenir sur
euh la première chose qu'il a faite
c'est pas wou on va sauver des vies
c'est wou le marché quoi quand il quand
on voit cette cette image moi je la
trouve dramatique c'est oui on va sauver
des vies pas oui champagne on a le
marché parce que c'était ça l'image donc
oui j'en ai que faire effectivement que
que ce que les contrats qui ont été très
mal négociés par la commission où ils
vont de 35 milliards de dollars ils vont
passer peut-être à 5 c'est pas mon
problème j'ai pas d'action chez pizer
tant pis vous gagnez combien
nous sommes à
€ net vous payez vos impôts en France
non c'est un prélève alors si les deux
c'est nouveau on paye un on a un
prélèvement automatique c'est un impôt
européen qui et plus puisque je vis en
France je suis aussi imposable en France
avec le foyer normal français vous payez
une dîme à votre partie oui de combien
de 10 %
c'est c'est ça fait partie du jeu c'est
normal voilà je suis là aussi grâce à
eux donc ça fait et puis ça permet aussi
de faire de de de de comment dire de
faire des actions au niveau local parce
que là je suis entre Bruxelles et
Strasbourg mais il faut pas oublier le
terrain on reviendra sur l'aspect
financier un peu plus
tard
imaginez-vous une ou un de nos auditeurs
nous écoute il a jamais entendu parler
de ses SMS entre Ursula venderleen et
céit qui d'autre Albert bourl PDG de P
en quelques mots qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé et est-ce que vous avez eu accès
au SMS alors en quelques mots crise
oblige
soi-disant donc il y a madame Ursula van
derlayen donc présidente de la
commission qui s'arroge le droit de
négocier par SMS avec Albert bourl au
sujet de la mise en place d'un contrat
pour l'achat des des vaccins qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait cette dame d'ailleurs
Ursula van derlayen euh normalement
elle préside la commission et c'est elle
qui met en place toutes les stratégies
de la commission elle est élu 5 ans par
qui alors ça aussi c'est intéressant son
son son parcours elle a été mise là
parce qu'il y a eu un scandale en
Allemagne quand elle était ministre de
la défense avec aussi des problèmes de
SMS où apparemment elle aussi elle
oublié ses SMS et elle avait fait des
marchés publics pour intéresser le
ministère de la Défense et avec des
cabinets de de de privé je crois
Mackenzie je peux vous compper j'ai
tellement de questions à vous poser je
suis infiniment désolé les SMS qu'on été
échangés c'était sur un téléphone
sécurisé ou c'était sur wanadou ou
Itinéris ou alors ben j'aimerais bien
savoir c'est tout le problème
c'est-à-dire que nous on a demandé à
avoir accès à ces SMS c'est un
journaliste qui a qui a soulevé le
problème euh effectivement la Commission
et même elle et même lors de l'audition
ils ont tous euh comment dire acquessé
sur le fait qu'il y a eu lors de la de
de la crise et comme il y avait vous
savez c'est c'est tout était fait à
distance ils ont utilisé le téléphone
donc on a demandé à avoir accès à ces
SMS effectivement parce que c'est au
regard des traités on a un droit le T
tous les les citoyens même ont le droit
d'avoir accès à tous les documents de la
Commission et donc on a considéré que le
SMS était faisait partie intégrante de
de ces textes qui sont normalement en
accès libre aux citoyens C sur C ligne
perso ou professionnel et ben c'était
une des questions parce que parce
qu'effectivement euh
euh de toute façon peut importe parce
que c'était une négociation d'un d'un
avec pour le compte de la Commission et
à C à ces deux à cette question elle n'a
pas pu répondre et euh et et d'ailleurs
c'est une des questions écrites que j'ai
faites que si c'était un un téléphone
euh de la commission il fallait qu'on
ait un accès direct effectivement la
Commission a dit qu'elle ne proposait
pas vous rendez compte elle ne propose
pas de de téléphone professionnel à la
Commission et aujourd'hui donc je vous
le dis c'est peut-être un scoop on vient
d'apprendre que le 4 décembre 2024
Ursula Verlen a signé je dans le sac
après si vous voulez comme il faut
sourcer si vous voulez je donne le
document c'est pas comme il faut sourcer
c'est il faut toujours sourcer tout à
fait je suis la première à le faire je
suis la première parce que je sais
exactement que c'est des c la petite
faille qui peut vous faire tomber et en
face de N c'est pas ça c'est vous pouz
incriminer quelqu'un sans avoir
suffisamment de PRU je me mets à la
place duçula bon il y a une épidémie ça
débarque de chez les chinois il y a un
laboratoire P4 qui est là-dedans on se
dit peut-être qu'ils ont militarisé un
bordel il faut tout de suite choper les
contrats parce que c'est permettez-moi
l'expression chin pour soi et Dieu pour
tous il faut y aller hop je connais
monsieur on se connaît depuis des années
tac tac je te fais trois SMS et là j'ai
mon Union européenne qui a les
vaccins c'est le miracle du SMS
non mais c'est vrai que que que c'est
comprenez mon angle je me fais l'avocat
du diable ouais
mais il y a quand même plein de comme
vous avez dit les faisceaux
d'indice non mais tout à l'heure vous
avez dit c'est important d'avoir des
faisceaux d'indice pour pour pour
arriver à enquêter pour enquêter et
arriver à une conclusion et c'est vrai
que dans cette dans ce ce cet épisode
moi je viens dire le feuilleton le SMS
fait partie du feuilleton et
effectivement dans ce feuilleton du SMS
normalement il y a cet accès à C SMS en
tout cas à toutes les documents qui
rentreraient dans dans dans la
négociation elle l'a toujours refusé et
aujourd'hui c'est ce que jeis je termine
avec cette cette nouveauté c'est que le
la puisqu'elle a été reconduite c'est
vrai qu'on a j'ai pas pu encore
expliquer comment elle a accédé au
pouvoir celui-là donc elle a été
exfiltré d'Allemagne ils l'ont placé à
la commission normalement c'étaitement
Fred Weber parce que vous savez c'est
quand aux élections c'est le parti qui
gagne le groupe Grou politique qui gagne
avec le parti à l'intérieur qui gagne
c'est le PPE donc c'est le l'aile droite
et à l'intérieur c'est la CDU c'est les
allemand donc c'était normalement le
Manfred Weber qui aurait dû avoir la
place de vaner Len mais suspicion oblige
pourquoi ils ont exfiltré pourquoi ils
ont mis cette personnes à ce moment-là
ça c'est une vraie question politique
moi est-ce que pas parce que elle
présentait mieux elle avait une très
belle casserole et je pense qu' on tient
aussi les gens avec les casseroles moi
je pense ci avec le recul que j'ai c'est
c'est une interprétation exactement
c'est mon interprétation je veux dire
quelqu'un qui a une casserole et ben on
peut lui faire faire ce qu'on veut voilà
c'est comme ça et et cette casserole lui
a permis pour moi effectivement
d'accéder à ce poste pour ça qu'elle a
même été reconduite malgré toutes les
critiques malgré aussi quand même ce
parce qu'il y a plusieurs procès qui
avaient été qui étit qui avaient été
poussé contre elle elle bénéficie de la
présomption d'innocence et elle a
l'immunité en plus hein hein bah ça
c'est leur immunité euh
qui qui qui don bénéficie ces ces
commissaires vous avez une immunité
ouais le temps le temps du Vendin mais
après elle peut-être levée et puis moi
je m'oppose pas qu'elle soit levée si
vraiment ça peut si ça peut vraiment
aider à la justice à enquêter moi il y a
pas de problème c'est pas une immunité
on va dire le totem pour me protéger si
vraiment là-dessus y il y a pas de
difficulté en tout cas à à répondre à la
justice si besoin c'est une immunité
dans les textes mais c'est surtout une
immunité pour nous protéger des attaques
euh C quelle révélation que vous voulez
faire ah oui c'est ça c'est important
oui bah oui le 4 décembre 2024 qu'est-ce
qu'elle signe parce qu'on parlait des
SMS ouais je vous dis je perd le fil et
et ben aujourd'hui parce que c'était pas
dans les textes suppression automatique
des SMS au bout de 6 mois non mais c'est
du foutage voilà de gueule donc donc ça
veut dire que que qu'en fait c'est ça la
résultante voyez on a mis on a mis on a
mis en exerg cette cette
problématique c'estd que la
problématique des SMS est-ce qu'il
fallait les intégrer dans les textes
c'estd parce que c'était ça une des
questions d'ailleurs la médiatrice on
avait échangé là-dessus la médiatrice
européenne c'est celle un peu qui est là
aussi comme nous lanceuse d'alerte pour
aussi contrôler la Commission et dire à
la commission ça c'est bien ça c'est pas
bien je vous recommande deux et la
médiatrice Émilie orily qui
malheureusement s'en va avait fait aussi
cette démarche auprès de la commission
elle avait dit ça serait bien d'intégrer
les SMS comme un texte administratif
comme un texte qui doit rentr dans les
traités donc l'accès au SMS ce qui tombe
sous le sens et bien non 4 décembre
qu'est-ce qu'ils disent le contraire
c'estàd qu'au bout de 6 mois suppression
automatique des SMS donc vous voyez un
peu mais pour tout le monde pour ceux de
la commission c'est le règlement
intérieur de la commission non mais
c'est une blague donc du coup là on
vient d'apprendre ça parce que c'est
sorti le 4 décembre et en ce moment on
est en train de rédiger des amendements
alors des amendements c'està direire
qu'on aménage le texte sur le contrôle
budgétaire donc c'est-àdire sur le
budget de la Commission et donc on a
déposé un amendement pour qu'ils
enlèvent tout de suite cet article parce
que c'est c'est encore une fois se
de nous ça va à l'encontre
effectivement des principes de
transparence on en a parlé au tout début
de l'émission et et et puis en plus
c'est un grand pied de nez à au procès à
toutes les revendications que nous avons
fait jusqu'à présent pour plus de
transparence pour plus de confiance
envers cette institution vous voulez
rajouter d'autres éléments continue un
peu le sujet ça fait 57 minutes que nous
sommes en direct vous il y AZ des choses
que vous voulez rajouter par rapport à
ce dossier oui avant
qu'on ce qui est choquant encore
aujourd'hui c'est que voilà bon il y a
eu la l'épidémie de grippe cet hiver on
parle plus trop de covid est-ce que et
on se rend compte encore une fois en
tout opacité que la Commission continue
à acheter des vaccins 142 millions de
vaccins auprès de moderna pour encore 4
ans mais ils ont une meilleure
efficacité
peut-être je ne sais pas je pas
essayé mais toujours toujours est-il que
c'est fait sans qu'il ait consultation
des parlementaire et ça ça commence à
être gênant mais on est en train de le
voir tous les jours il y a un scandale
dire celui-là effectivement il est passé
à la trappe mais là tous les jours on
est en train de voir que voilà ok donc
je le garde pour après ouais gardez-le
sous le coude je vais vous poser une
question qui va peut-être vous semblez
bête l'Union européenne c'est bien ou
c'est pas bien
bah aujourd'hui c'est pas bien
aujourd'hui c'est pas bien parce que il
y a une dérive qu'est-ce qui est
bien
aujourd'hui un
exemple qu'est-ce qui est bien dans
l'Union européenne on est tous ensemble
on se sert les coudes s'il y a un
méchant Poutine ou un méchant Donald
Trump ou un méchant n'importe qui qui
débarque on on se met tous ensemble on
fait bloc comme un seul homme on met nos
finances en commun on peut faire baisser
prix des marchés on peut on est
fort aujourd'hui l'Union européenne est
est en grande difficulté c'est vrai donc
ce qui est
bien c'est pas nouveau c'està dire
qu'effectivement je trouve que
finalement l'espace Schengen c'est
plutôt pas mal libre circulation des
biens et des produits c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt bien moi j'ai envie
de dire le fait qu'on puisse avoir avec
notre téléphone pas changer de ligne et
pour être dans toute l'Europe avec la
même ligne et s qui est de frais
supplémentaires c'est plutôt
intéressant mais on
constate et moi je l'ai vu en 2019 quand
je suis arrivé une
dérive de la commission dérive à vouloir
plus de compétences qui ne sont pas les
les siennes c'est-à-dire en matière de
santé on l'a vu on l'a vu lors de la
crise covid en matière de défense
aujourd'hui je suis sur un dossier
pareil elle veut gérer aussi la défense
est-ce que demain il faut envoyer des
troupes en Ukraine c'est aussi voilà
c'est est-ce que la Commission doit
gérer ça on le voit au niveau de
l'agriculture sur la PAC depuis des
années bah la baissé et et puis cet
argent de la PAC on on se rend compte
qu'il est parti où cet argent de la PAC
il est allé pour maintenant on le voit
ça va on est en plein dents c'est allé
pour c'est parti pour rémunérer des ONG
euh pour finalement faire goberber euh
aux Européens le pacte vert c'est ça
mais ça sort d'où ça bah ça c'est les on
ça c'est le scandale de il y a 2
semaines c'estàd qu'on se rend compte
que Monsieur Timmermans qui était
vice-président de premier mandat avec
Van der lyen euh a finan a fait financer
sous un programme qui s'appelle life des
ONG dit vertes pour faire du lobbying
auprès des parlementaires pour faire
accepter bah tout le Green Deal le Green
Deal c'est le moi j'appelle ça le le le
le le scrologie c'est-à-dire qu'on
essayer de vous de faire changer par
exemple l'exemple que tout le monde
connaît aujourd'hui les voitures à
moteur thermique un voiture électrique
euh on essaie maintenant de de vous de
de remplacer la viande bovvine par de la
viande artifice ciel on essaie de
remplacer les farines classiques de blé
par de la farine d'insecte donc tout ce
projet on le les bâtiments ou on doit
maintenant les rénover compléter un peu
comment ça donne du goût ça complète bah
je sais pas là non plus j'ai pas
essayé je sais pas si aujourd'hui le
français le matin il a envie d'acheter
sa baguette avec 20% 4 % d'insectes et
demain 100 % je ve dire d'abord qu'on a
d'abord c'est pas la priorité je
j'imagine des Français ils ont ce qu'ils
veulent c'est vivre bien on sa sécurité
avoir un petit pouvoir d'achat mais
qu'on leur change la baguette enfin
c'est pas le sujet et puis c'est pas
l'envie et donc scandale après scandale
on se rend compte qu'effectivement
l'argent qui était normalement prévu
pour protéger les agriculteurs B il est
il est il est transférer vers des ONG
pour faire la promotion du Green Deal
pour acheter les médias pour vendre le
narratif de l'Europe c'est bien l'Europe
ça vous protège donc on est là on est en
plein scandale parce que c'est sourcé
c'est il y a eu des enquêtes de fê où
c'est simplement des wiir de bureau de
de couloir il y il y a et quand vous
dites acheter les médias c'est pas c'est
acheter des des des encarts de pub c'est
pour graisser la pâte c'est pour
financer la liberté d'expression c'est
pour financer les médias quand vous
dites acheter ça tout de suite c'est un
caractère oui c'est dur hein c'est dur
mais c'était transparent alors l'exemple
là que nous parler des 132 millions là
exactement ces 132 millions d'euros que
Madame Van derlayen c une aide à la
presse alors c'est c'est une question
puisqu'on vient de la prendre parce que
souvent et je remercie certains médias
de donner ces informations parce que
souvent il donnent des informations que
même nous au sein du Parlement nous
n'avons pas ah oui c'est vrai parce que
pour le coup je vous donne cette cette
cet exemple quand j'ai appris que les
ONG vertes faisaient du lobbying étaient
payé par la Commission la Commission
donne de l'argent au lob à aux ONG verts
pour faire du lobbing auprès des
parlementaires pour faire accepter la
réglementation euh j'ai donc interrogé
la Commission dans laquelle je suis qui
s'appelle commission comptte contrôle
budgétaire parce que j'avais lu dans la
presse que c'était que on pouvait avoir
accès parce que je le savais pas je me
dis déjà comment ça se fait qu'un
collègue qui débarque je je suis pas
complotiste mais qui débarque euh dans
cette commission c'est déjà où il faut
retrouver les contrats moi c'est mon
deuxième mandat je je ne savais pas donc
lesjà je me suis dit je vais vérifier
pourquoi il le sait avant moi donc déjà
j'ai vu que le gars avant travailler
c'est un
parlementaire nouveau Pays-Bas qui
travaillait pour le PPE et qui était
dans le cabinet de monfred Weber et
c'est lui qui a sorti l'affaire donc je
me suis dit il a pas eu l'information
qui est tomber du ciel parce que pour
chercher un contrat c'est comme si vous
cherchiez une une aiguille dans une
boîte de FO donc moi vous avez pas
cherché il plus d'expérience Imposs
qu'est-ce que non mais ça c'est ça c'est
votre interprétation Imposs impossible
je l' fait et juste une question je fais
un petit peu le je fais le
malin les lobbyistes au Parlement
européen ils doivent être sur une liste
ouais il y a une registre de
transparence et il était dedans
peut-être euh qui il bah je sais pas
vous m'avez dit l'Union européenne par
l'intermédiaire de la commission qui
donne des sous
donc c du lobing et donc s'il faisaient
du lobbing ils étaient encartés ils
avaient une petite alors effectivement
ça c'est ces ONG vertes sont
effectivement
enregistrés dans le registre de
transparence mais c'est pas là qu'on a
vu le bug le vrai bug qu'on a vu c'est
que quand on va dans la commission
contrôle qu'on demande avoir accès au
contrat et là pour le coup pour avoir
accès au contrat 1 je dois signer une
décharge pour dire que ce que je vois
sur l'ordinateur je dois ne pas le dire
non mais c'est énorme
quand je sors le contrat sur mon ordi il
y a écrit mon nom Virginie Jon partout
c'estàd que si je fais une photo je me
fais après je ne peux pas la diffuser
sinon je suis sanctionné donc ce que je
vois c'est ma parole vous voyez ça aussi
c'est incroyable et j'ai lu vite fait le
contrat et oui effectivement ben c'est
700000 € qui sont donnés à cette ONG
alors j'ai plus le nom mais bon c'est
écrit dans les journaux vous faites on
vert Franck Timmermans projet life
700000 € tomb tout de suite sur
l'article et vous avez exactement le nom
de l'ONG mais moi ce qui ce qui est
choquant c'est un pour avoir accès au
contrat il faut vraiment être un expert
parce que parce que ça tombe pas du ciel
ce qui veut dire que derrière il y a des
règlements de compte c'est ça en fait la
lecture c'est dire que celui ce nouveau
député qui avantraé dans le cabinet de
monfred Weber du PPE savait qu'il y a un
problème savait exactement qu'il y avait
un problème avec ses contrats c'est pour
ça qui est allé le chercher qu' l'a
sorti c'est lui qui sort le le le en
scoop l'information
ça c'est votre interprétation ou il vous
l'a dit c'est mon c'est mon
interprétation mais parce qu'il faut
faire ça dans ce Parlement parce que
rien n'est neutre c'està-dire que chaque
député il y en a 720 je vous ai dit et
si vous regardez au moins un quart ils
sont aussi dans des Fing tank où ils ont
un passé dans un réseau ou ils sont pas
là par hasard il y en a beaucoup qui
sont pas là par hasard donc c'est aussi
intéressant de voir parce que quand vous
dites
influence corruption tout à
l'heure il y a il y a pas de il y a rien
est neutre c'est une gros le l'Union
européenne est une groste grosse machine
Afrique et a intérêt la Pfizer c'est
l'exemple type
euhreession bah attendez 35 milliards de
de dollars c'est c'est un petit peu de
fric quand même hein ils sont pas sont
pas venus par hasard combi de Z il y a
combien de zéro milliard ben il y en a
un paquet combien de quoi il y a combien
de zéos à 1 milliard bah 6
non donne pas la réponse
neuf vous pouvez remercier le caméraman
mais non mais vous me troublez là j'aime
pas les chiffres je parle voilà de toute
façon ça change quoi un milliard ça
reste ça reste un milliard
ou là c'est
donc pour en revenir sur sur ces
contrats c'estàd que même l'accès moi en
tant que parlementaire on me le
limite c'est-à-dire que quand je sors le
contrat je dois le je vois la mention
Virginie Geon je ne peux pas le
récupérer et après le diffuser c'est
comme quand tu es un policier consulte
un fichier Stix ah ben ça je sais pas je
connais pas le fichier stick fich je me
rappelle plus si ça fait s'appelle stick
ou quoi ouais je vous ai dit j'ai fait
qu'un mois de stage j'ai pas été plus
loin et puis après j'ai pas j'ai pas
j'ai j'ai pas été
interrogé heureusement je chouche du
bois pour pour d'autres fait mais voilà
un petit peu le le contexte et ça c'est
un exemple parmi d'autres euh où
effectivement vous avez vous avez des
cas mais quand on regarde alors je sais
pas si on peut maintenant s'exprimer sur
le sujet c'est c'est c'est pareil quand
on dit les influences et quand je dis
que a beaucoup de députés au moins
un/art sont mis là et aussi ont des
intérêts à l'extérieur extérieur
c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'ils travaillent
pas dans un f tank est-ce qu'ils sont
pas dans des dans des des groupes de des
réseau comment on appelle ça vous voyez
tout en noir non non parce que les S
tank la plupart c'est des des
rassemblements de vieux bourgeois qui
essayent de réfléchir ah oui qui
essayent de il y a pas de problème
d'amener un peu de de connaissance qui
essaent de réfléchir sur des sujets
importants pour la
démocratie et ces gens cotisent
gentiment voilà il faut aussi voir les
choses positivement
ouais mais le problème c'est c'est je
l'entends mais
quand mais quand quand ils utilisent de
l'argent qui normalement devrait être
servir aux Français comme pour les
agriculteurs effectivement c'est
choquant c'est comme je l'ai dit
l'argent une partie de l'argent de la PC
pourquoi l'argent de la pack a diminué
pour finalement financer ce type de F
tank ce type d'ONG ce type de de de
conseiller extérieur pour faire
avaler des réglementations qui qui vont
à l'encontre des intérêts des Français
euh pour favoriser certaines compagnies
là on a parlé de Pfizer euh donc c'est
ça le le le aujourd'hui la le le
problème de cette union européenne et
quand vous m'avez dit est-ce que c'est
bien et j'ai du mal à trouver le côté
bien parce que je vois les dérives de
cette de cette union européenne de cette
commission qui finalement défend des
défend des intérêts privés des intérêts
aussi d'g et pas les intérêt l'intérêt
commun normalement cette union
européenne cette Europe que moi en tout
cas je j'ai à cœur c'est c'est d'abord
de de défendre les intérêts des Français
en priorité l'argent qu'il c'est 23 23
millions de de d'euros
Converse dans dans dans dans 23
milliards voyez vous troublé avec les
chiffres 23 milliards qu'on verse dans
le pot de l'Union européenne on en
récupère 12 et le et sur ces 12
finalement on arrive on arrive même pas
à les rétribuer correctement à ceux qui
en ont le plus besoin
au contraire on les étouffe sous des
normes parce que c'est ça la machine de
Bruxelles c'est c'est toujours plus de
normes moi je le vois quand j'ai suivi
le dossier des
emballages déchets recyclage d'emballage
et bien on asphixie encore plus nos
concitoyens voilà encore plus de tri
encore plus de contrainte pour
l'industrie où doivent toutes changer
leur leur leur chaîne de de de montage
l'histoire du bouchon sur la la
bouteille franchement ça qui a demandé
ça et ça vous avez derrière tous ces ONG
ces bureaux d'études qui sont là
derrière pour inventer ils prennent de
l'argent de l'Europe pour finalement
mettre ça en place et c'est pas
l'intérêt c'est pas pour moi aussi c'est
le le le bien que l'Union européenne met
en place pour est-ce que vous pensez de
temps en temps contre vous-même comment
est-ce que vous pensez contre vous-même
de temps en temps vous êtes pas dit bon
lesg les les comment qu'est-ce que je
fais là c'est ça non vous êtes pas dit
bon bah les tortues elle mange trop de
bouchons elle mange trop de de
cotontige les tortues le continent de
plastique les chargeur de téléphone
universel l'intelligence non pas
l'intelligence artificielle qu'est-ce
qu'on pourrait dire bon le plastique ça
pollue et les ONG qui ont les deux pieds
à ramasser les bouts de plastique ou
chalu ils on av peut-être pas ils ont
peut-être assez ils ont fait remonter à
l'Union européenne que bon bah les
bouchons on en retrouvé plein que il
faudrait peut-être un petit peu se
débrouiller alors il y avait peut-être
des associations qui récupéraient les
bouchons pour en faire autre chose
mais vous voyez tout en noir non parce
que on est déjà une économie de
recyclage vertueuse bah si quand même la
France est quand même pionnier avec
l'Italie en Europe je veux dire on n pas
attendu le Bruxelles pour déjà recycler
ça fait des années on n'est pas les
derniers élèves sur la carte européenne
ce qui est plus choquant c'est
effectivement de voir des fois que nos
déchets sont envoyés à B et brûlé à Bali
là oui ça c'est un problème et ça je
suis d'accord que il faut lutter contre
ce type de pollution ou en Afrique
effectivement là on va envoyer nos
futures voitures à moteur thermique
parce qu'il faut pas se lurer on va
faire quoi ces voitures thermiques une
fois que tout le monde aura changé sa
voiture moi je l contre ça fa avoir
l'argent pour changer sa voiture déjà
déjà ça la première première des choses
mais c'est le même principe c'estàd que
qu'on est on a
déjà un recyclage vertueux plus c'est
toujours mieux que mieux plus que plus à
un moment donné ça va étouffer les gens
et à un moment donné ça va être l'effet
inverse donc je regrette effectivement
pour que pour ce dossier finalement
n'est pas dans l'intérêt des Français
coûte beaucoup d'argent et le résultat
finalement pour nous est zéro puisque
déjà ce ce modèle vertueux existit avant
de changer de sujet je vous pose une
question qui n'a rien à voir ou
peut-être si je vous dis fonction
exponentielle ça vous fait penser à quoi
et qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est un truc de mat ça mais moi
je suis nulle en
donc ouis je marrête là voilà alors
maintenant on va parler corruption
ingérence étrangère que ce soit des
Russes des Qataris des Américains des
Marocains de tout le monde est-ce que
l'Union européenne c'est pas un grand
cirque où on laisse des des
députés sans protection avec des
téléphones pas
sécurisé et que on a vu très récemment
qui est-ce qui s'est qui avait beaucoup
de sous cache qui faisait quoi cette
vous catar gate c'est ah le catar gatece
là on a fait le le
per non le catar gate qu'est-ce que
c'est le catar gate est-ce qu'il y a eu
un Rusia gate un amerriicano gate un
maroco gate un israelo Green Gate là
j'en ai passé là c'est le petit Green
Gate que je vous ai dit parce que c'est
le c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt
parce que ça veut dire mais je pasevenir
c'estàdire que toutes ces ONG qui pulent
autour de la Bruxelles la Commission on
des intérêts financi car gate c'est quoi
c'est mais j'en ai un autre aussi
d'exemple qui qui est pas sorti mais qui
est aussi important ok katarget c'est
qui c'est Eva Kelly donc une socialiste
grecque très jolie ancienne
présentatrice télé avec qui fil parfait
amour avec un assistant
italien qui travaill aussi au Parlement
et qui et qui avait des accointances
avec un ancien parlementaire monsieur
Panzeri un Italien des acintances bah
ils avaient des intérêts communs
apparemment puisquil travailler ensemble
et que du coup sur la question du Qatar
ils ont pu monter apparemment une une
euh une organisation non gouvernementale
encore une fois je crois qu'il y en
avait deux ça s'appelait attendez de
mémoire ça s'appelait fight
impunity la blague hein combattre
l'impunité c'était la c'était la l'ONG
de ce fameux Panzeri et c'était la la la
c'était la la ma fait vérifier la
machine à cache de panzerie qui lui
permettait avec cette ONG de finalement
continuer à pulluler au sein du
Parlement européen et donc Eva Kelly qui
faisait partie un petit peu de ce ce
petit groupe et bien on l' on l'a chopé
un matin chez elle avec je crois 800000
€ en cash l'argent de Mamie c'était quoi
ben apparemment c'était l'argent du
Qatar elle avait eu des cadeaux elle
avait eu du cash il y avait toute la
famille autour il y a une enquête qui
qui a été menée elle a été en prison je
crois 6 ou 7 mois et ce qui était
choquant aussi c'est que bon voilà
c'était flagrant qu' avait un un des
suspicions hein corruption avec le Qatar
parce que c'était la même année
effectivement où il y avait vous saviez
le
le le football le comment s'appelle le
Mondial de football au Qatar et il y
avait beaucoup de gens qui critiquaient
le fait qu'il recevaiit le les
footballeur parce que il y avait des des
problématiques liées au droit du travail
l'esclavagisme non respect du droit du
travail et donc il y avait des grosses
critiques autour de cet événement et EV
Kelli plusieurs fois lors des
commissions et même même Inter venu au
Parlement benah elle tenait des propos
complètement euh
à en faveur en tout cas qui des propos
en faveur du Qatar pour dire au
contraire qui respectait le droit du
travail enfin bref elle av fait l'éloge
de de des cataris au regard de de
l'emploi et du droit du travail de la
protection des des ouvriers donc c'est
vrai qu'à partir de là je pense que même
les socialistes sont posé la question
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe parce que
c'était pas du tout leur point de vue
donc est sorti cette histoire du
catariette et là c'est c'est vrai qu'on
a vu cette cette cette cette affaire qui
a démontré qu'il y avait des influences
des ingérences en tout cas certains
utilisai le mandat de députés européen
pour finalement conforter une politique
protéger une politique donc vous avez le
Qatar gate il y avait on en a très peu
parlé aussi il y avait aussi le Maroc
gate où d'autres députés avaient été
pris
aussi avec des des des comment dire des
hôtels des goodies non des hôtels
c'était des hôtels payés par le Maroc
pour là aussi euh promouvoir l'image du
Maroc ou alors parce qu'en fait je
comprends pas c'était c'était des
séjours organisés au Maroc oui des chos
des des cadeaux quoi on les invite au
Maroc tout frais payé non mais des
cadeau c'est-à-dire que ils payaient le
billet d'avion et l'hôtel et eux ils
payaient la bouffe sur place c'esttait
50 50 comment ça se passe alors le
détail je ne les connais pas mais ce que
j'ai lu c'est que par exemple certains
étaient invités à Marrakech et euh était
invité de de de de de Bruxelles gratuit
à marrakeche le séjour les Français ils
font peut-être ça aussi non c'est-à-dire
les Français du soft power est-ce que le
ked d'oré appelle par exemple des petits
chinois ou des petits russes ou des
petits américainsis pas pour venir alors
je ne sais pas moi je vous parle de
est-ce que si c'est des journalistes qui
viennent est-ce qu'il payent le billet
d'avion et la la puissance étrangère
paye l'hôtel 50 50 comme ça chacun garde
de son intégrité alors là là pourquoi ça
fait un peu de bruit au sein de l'Union
européenne parce que c ces cadeaux
étaient reliés aussi derrière à un poste
au sein du Parlement européen peut-être
notamment dans les commissions qui
s'appellent marèche où ces gens sont
sont membres des députés sont membres de
cette commission et dans cette
commission parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
délégations où vous avez des relations
avec l'extérieur vous avez donc et moi
je suis présente dans plusieurs de ces
délégations et dans ces délégations
souvent on prenez des résolutions à
l'encontre d'un pays et souvent c'est
plutôt pour parce que il respectent pas
les droits de l'homme ça ça c la valeur
est symbolique mais elle reste
symbolique mais elle est importante pour
le pays donc en fait l'idée
qui qui que certains utilise c'est
lobbyist on va
dire Qatar Maroc agent d'influence agent
d'influence voilà exactement c'est le
terme et bien c'est d'utiliser de faire
des cadeaux à certains députés pour
assouplir la la rédaction d'une
résolution qui ira qui irait sanctionner
un état mais mais pourquoi les députés
il renvoi pas les cadeaux bah
demandez-leur moi je vous avez reçu des
cadeaux vous non est-ce qu'il y a une
puissance étrangère qui essayer de vous
tamponner non est-ce que vous avez été
approché non pourquoi je vois votre non
parce que je réfléchis parce que parce
que il y a pas besoin de réfléchir non
parce que j'ai j'ai j'étais quand vous
dites approché bien sûr je suis parti en
mission et que j'ai fait euh j'ai
j'étais euh alors avec mes propres fonds
je suis allée au Pakistan euh ouais je
suis allée au Pakistan parce que je
voulais voir euh euh je voulais voir un
peu ce qui se passait au cachemir le
conflit qu'il a avec l'Inde et moi voilà
je suis curieuse de nature j'ai ses
opportunité c'est vrai qu'on a on est on
est très solité sol c'est une
opportunité qui s'est passé comment
c'estàdire que il y a le monsieur de
l'ambassade du du Pakistan qui est venu
vous voir en disant
Virginie tu veux pas faire une petite
semaine de vacances au cachemir
on te paye le billet d'avion l'hôtel Le
fixeur sur place le taxi cel je me le
suis donc vous avez tout payé de a
est-ce que vous avez demandé un visa
professionnel ou un visa touristique je
me souviens honnêtement je me souviens
plus faut que je vérifie non de toute
façon c'est toujours un visa lié à mon
mandat donc c'est pas loisir mais je je
je me suis payé mon propre voyage mais
sur place après effectivement vous êtes
accueilli pendant une semaine par les
autorités donc donc après euh euh mes
autorités pour pour aller je peux pas
aller toute seule sur le front du
Cachmir donc forcément je vais
rencontrer les autorité militaire donc
là on est pris en charge de de l'hôtel
pour aller rencontrer les forces les
forces armées mais euh mais mais c'est
juste pour en fait et là c'était
intéressant parce qu'il voulait nous
montrer le côté Pakistan Cachmir parce
que j'avais fait la dernière j'avais vu
l'autre côté j'étais allé en Inde pour
voir le cachmir'est ce qui passait de
l'autre côté pour avoir Mo sur
dispositif avec oui ce même dispositif
pour voir pour pour avoir voilà un point
de vue des deux et c'est important de
voir vous étiez euh euh voilé non pas du
tout pas du tout je suis à Islamabad ça
s'est très bien passé pas voilé pas de
contrainte par rapport à à à la tenue ou
ou même au propos parce que des fois
vous pouvez dire voilà vous êtes invité
vous avez comme vous savez quand vous
allez voir Macron vous devez à l'avance
donner euh vos questions bien là non là
on arrive on prépare rien c'est sans
filtre on poste toutes les les questions
qu'on souhaite et euh et parce qu'ils
ont ils ont pour la pour le coup ils ont
compris que c'est important pour eux de
tout ouvrir de tout montrer pour qu'on
se fasse notre propre opinion et et et
pour conforter certains à prendre part
ou pas à certaines résolutions donc donc
donc je l'utilise pas politiquement mais
c'est plutôt humainement pour moi c'est
vraiment vous étiez sur place vous
utilisiez la carte bleue du Parlement
européen ou votre carte bleue à vous
c'est ma carte bleue à moi ours rien du
tout non non non non non non non c'est
ma carte bleue c'est un voyage c'est
voilà c'est si je vous dis vous voulez
rajouter quelques mots non non parce que
non voilà c'était le c'était la
parenthèse c'est le seul de vos voyages
qui qui était qui considérait avoir les
les choses vous avez fait que le
Pakistan et l'Inde j'ai fait beaucoup de
missions pour le Parlement dans le cadre
de mes délégations euh donc je suis je
suis allée ben il y a pas longtemps au
Kazakhstan la semaine prochaine je pars
au Turkménistan parevenenu avec un un
tapis ben si je l'achète je l'achète
avec mes mon argent vous avez pas reçu
des sacs à main ouais non des petits
Goudies un peu chers non parce qu'on est
obligé de le déclarer et jusqu'à présent
j'ai eu quelques oui j'ai eu quelques
cadeaux mais ça c'est quoi ben rien
c'est des petites assiettes vous savez
c'est jamais rien non c'est des elles
sont elles sont dans mon bureau elles
sont mises en avant la délégation du
Portugal non c'était là je suis allée
début janvier en Inde pour voir un petit
peu comment il s'organisit au niveau de
la tech parce que comme je suis dans la
commission marché intérieur je suis
encore tous les sujets du numérique et
c'était une délégation officielle du
Parlement pour aller en Inde donc j'ai
fait mumbaai bangalor et puné ou mumbaai
puné bangalor pour voir un petit peu
tous les gens de la tech et il vous
offre vous savez les petites assiettes
qui veulent rien avec votre nom donc
comme ça a une valeur en dessous de 150
€ vous êtes pas obligé de le déclarer
donc vous avez appris quelques mots en
ind pas du tout vous avez appris
quelques mots en dou rien du tout c'est
trop dur naï
naï non non impossible mais c'est
intéressant même pas dire bonjour non
rien du tout je comment ça va non rien
désolé vous êtes plus plus plus fort que
moi ah ouais bah c'est dur merost je
pense qu'ils me l'ont dit mais j'ai j'ai
c'était c'était compliqué mais cétait
intéressant de voir un peu la dynamique
qui a en Inde vraiment et quand vous
m'avez posé la question tout à l'heure
entre la différence entre patriotes et
nationaliste ils sont considérés comme
un gouvernement nationaliste moi j'ai
envie de dire quand j'ai vu pendant une
semaine ce qui s'établissait là-bas
c'est plutôt pour moi gouvernement
patriote dans le sens où c'est le made
in India c'est toutes les chaînes
d'approvisionnement maintenant ils
recentrent tout en Inde c'est d'abord on
défend et on protège notre marché donc
voilà je bon on va on va passer on va
revenir sur les catar gate les machin
gate les r gate les machin r gate juste
après question stupide quand vous étiez
dans X ou Y pays comme ça en
délégation vous avez essayer de les
tester un peu pour voir si vous étiez
surveillé genre le soir sortir alors au
Pakistan blonde compliqué euh vous avez
essayé de sortir je suis sorti en PIST
mais sans demander la vie à personne
sans votre bodyguard sans votre
opérateur sans sans personne c'estd vous
sortez et là vous essayez de voir qui
vous suit alors je vais donner des
exemples concrets parce que c'est vrai
que c'est sinon on peut pas se rendre
compte moi je suis allée plusieurs fois
dans des pays pour observer des
élections avec quel pays j'ai fait
Nigéria sierraaléone Moldavie ah ouais
ouais c'est pas mal et et et c'est vrai
que c'est une délégation officielle il y
a beaucoup de tension parce que bah
c'est des c'est un moment d'élection euh
donc vous pouvez considérer que votre
vie elle peut voilà elle peut être
risquée et vous pensez effectivement que
vous avez des bodyguardes donc non non
on arrive dans l'hôtel hein euh et après
le soir on fait ce qu'on veut et même si
toute la journée on voit différentes
autorités ça fait partie de la
délégation c'est délégation très
officielle donc on voit tous les partis
politiques on voit les les bureaux
électoraux on voit les associations on
voit des ONG on voit un peu tout le tout
tout le monde qui représente les
élections puis le soir à partir de 20h
si vous voulez vous balader vous allez
vous balader donc c'est vrai que le
nigéa c'est c'est compliqué parce qu'il
y a rien hein je suis allé au cerraléon
cerra-aléon je su si après on est parti
se balader à l'extérieur mais pareil
sans sans bodyguard vous avez rencontré
des dissidents politiques vous avez
rencontré des des des associations de
femmes exactement on regarde tout ce
type de de de de et la société civile
effectivement avec des associations de
femmes pour les enfants on a vu et ce
qui est intéressant au nigéa on a vu
toutes les obédiences religieuses voilà
mais ça fait partie du jeu vous avez un
ami imaginaire
euh pas vraiment vous croyez en Dieu
ouais je crois à tous les Dieu c'est je
suis très ouverte là-dessus je crois
voilà effectivement j'ai ma préférée
c'est Marie
Jésus mais après moi je parle à tout le
monde je trouve que c'est important
d'ailleurs un de mes meilleurs livres
que j'aime lire c'est Socrate Jésus
Boudha de Frédéric Lenoir et voilà
revenons au casatarget oui madame
sacamin cach elle retravaille au
Parlement ou elle a été VI non elle a
été pas elle a pas été réélue mais
pendant toute cette affaire parce que il
y avait encore 2 ans à finir dans le
mandat elle était elle pouvait voter
elle était encore au Parlement
c'est-à-dire que
présomption d'innocence parce que
c'était qu'une enquête ouais mais quand
même c'est quand même choquant de voir
qu'il y a eu qu'il a ce s scandale prise
en flagrant d'lit je crois que son
immunité elle aelle elle l' pas elle a
elle a été levée mais du coup c'était
compliqué parce que elle s'est accroché
derrière derrière son immunité et mais
par contre en attendant le procès et
bien elle figurait encore dans
l'hémicycle et elle continuait à voter
son droit de vote é encore là
US ça vous fait penser à quoi US aid la
prononciation donc si on voit US c'est
qu'il a forcément doit y avoir R ou
portugala ou
pour c'est le le c'est comme on a dit
c'est l'affaire des ONG vertes c'est un
peu l'arbre qui cche la forêt et là
effectivement avec le vent qui vient des
États-Unis où il met en avant bah tout t
nos suspicionss finalement en fait c'est
ça c'est d que toutes nos suspicis avec
ses interférences ses ingérences ces
ceses ces agents extérieurs et bien
finalement nous donne raison donc USAID
aujourd'hui nous a démontré que il y
avait de l'argent des des États-Unis qui
allait directement financer des ONG de
l'autre côté de la planète à des fins
c'est pour aider des gens qui ont faimou
alors c'est ce que j'ai dit des des des
des des gens qui sont dans besoin si
c'est pour acheter des sacs de riz et
pour aider la population à lutter contre
la famille pourquoi pas mais en fait
c'était pas dans le programme d'USD on a
vu que c'était aussi pour payer des des
bandes dessinées sur le trans transgenre
au Pérou je l'ai dit il y a pas
longtemps dans une de mes interventions
on voit aussi queusd aussi a été
l'argent a été détourné pour financer
des médias pour lutter contre la
désinformation euh donc financer des S
tank ouais financer des f tank aussi des
S tank où il y aurait des militaires
français des diplomates français et des
d'autres personnes françaises alors vous
pensez à qui là parce que vous inquiétez
pas on est en train de creuser là ouais
voilà parce que le sujet effectivement
il est sur la table moi aussi avec mon
équipe on essayer de regarder ça de plus
près parce que cette semaine est sorti
un nouveau rapport concernant toutes les
ONG qui ont été rémunéré par la
commission pour faire la promotion des
valeurs européennes donc là on a ouvert
le c'est bien bah oui c'est non mais
c'est bien c'est bien quand on quand
vous êtes europhile mais quand on veut
ça c'est c'est de la supputation oui
voilà du diable oui mais c'est pour ça
que je vous répond c'est pour ça que je
dis si on est c'est pour ça que j'ai mis
le si on est europile et et et et si on
est pote avec ces ONG bien sûr que ça
nous intéresse je vous donne un
exemple madame sylvie Goulard qui était
donc la candidate pour être commissaire
au marché intérieur à la place de
Thierry Breton euh qui était secrétaire
à la Défense sous Macron mais un petit
temps et euh et donc est arrivé au
Parlement européen elle pensait avoir ce
mandat de de commissaire européenne et
on a découvert dans son CV qu'elle était
dans un Fing tank américain pas de
problème elle a le droit elle a le droit
mais 11000 € par mois pendant 3 ans
alors c'est pas comme au final ça
revient presque au même montant que Eva
Kelly avec ses son son ses sacs mais
elle a pas pu nous dire pourquoi et
qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait pendant 3 ans
avec ce Fing tank elle a payé des impôts
en
France peut-être mais en tout cas elle
n'a pas pu produire quoi que ce soit sur
ces 11000 € par mois ce qui veut dire
que ça ça veut dire ça veut dire quoi en
fait est-ce que elle donnait des des
renseignements à cet institut bergruen à
l'époque s'appelait comme ça basé à Los
Angeles ça c'est votre interprétation
ben c'est une question regarde je vous
supputation non parce que là je je pose
une question donc c'est pas une
subutation mais quand vous dites qu'elle
a été incapable de produire quoi que ce
soit j'ai posé la question et elle vous
a dit euh ben elle ça fait partie d' ma
première audition que j'ai faite à la
Commission et c'est là que elle n'a pas
répondu et c'est pour cette raison
qu'elle a pas obtenu ce poste de
commissaire et qu'on s'est retrouvé avec
Thierry Breton alors question quand il
se passe des choses comme ça
c'est-à-dire que elle est pas capable de
vous donner son emploi du temps pour
dire voilà elle a rencontré Pierre Paul
JAAC ils ont discuté de ce sujet sur
l'industrie
ou les relations entre l'Europe et les
États-Unis d'une
façon profonde et elle vous elle vous a
pas donné son emploi du temps ou elle
vous a pas dit qui étaient ses collègues
de son groupe de travail dans ce sigle
tant que là quelle était le sujet de de
son groupe de travail où elle vous a
donné d'autres éléments elle a dit non
je me rappelle plus je comprends pas
bien elle n'a pas pu produire
a elle n'a pas pu produire quoi que ce
soit et encore moins parce qu'à un
moment donné elle nous a répondu euh que
c'était une société euh euh de conseil
parce qu'à un moment donné en 2 jours il
y avait des éditions sur de jours donc
je lui dit d'accord donc donnez-nous le
business plan
ou le le le le le le bilan le le le
enfin l'état des compes du groupe du
travail exactement et là elle m'a
regardé la réponse qu'elle a donné elle
a bien vu queelle s'était taillé une une
balle d' pied tirer une balle d' pied
dans ces cas-là et donc du oui non Alley
et donc du coup elle a compris queelle
avait fait l'erreur d'être rentrer dans
ce jeu de répondre aux questions
concernant euh la la la sa fonction
auprès l'Institut berguen et donc donc
elle a fauté et c'est pour cette raison
qu'elleelle n'a pas été adoubé dans ce
dans cette fonction nous on débarque on
vous a fait venir pour ça pour
comprendre question dans ces cas-là nous
en France on a la DGSI
ouais on a maintenant la DGSE avec
Nicolas qui a fait DGSI
DGSE quand il y a un politique qui
commence à se faire tamponner quand il y
a un politique X Y ou influenceur qui va
XY la DGSI elle sent elle fait le tour
elle fait le pédigré elle fait les
impôts elle fait les lignes
téléphoniques elle met des gens en
surveillance elle met des gens derrière
la connexion wifi elle met tout ça et
puis à l'étranger la DGSE fait son taf
de temps en
temps
correctement et elle surveille parce que
nos politiques ns législateurs nos
personnages public c'est quand même
important pour la défense du
territoire et il faut surveiller un peu
tout ça ils font leur taf ouais vous à
l'échelle européenne est-ce qu'il y a
des flics qui vous protègent est-ce que
vous avez un service par exemple je
prends le dossier Pegasus ça vous parle
Pegasus qu'est-ce que c'est Pegasus
c'est bah l'affaire où il y a eu de
l'espionnage dans les téléphones pour de
certains parlementaires et on s'est
rendu compte c'était des gouvernements
qui avaient piloter ça qui avait acheté
ce ou des sociétés privé ou des sociétés
privées qui avait acheté cette
application pour mettre sous écoute
certaines certaines personnalités pour
écoute prise de contrôle du téléphone de
la caméra du micro et des SMS bon j'en
pass les capacités votre téléphone il a
été audité par un service oui je l'ai
fait auditer cette année par un service
de la Commission de du Parlement et mais
ils sont venus à vous ou c'est vous non
c'est moi qui ai fait cette démarche
parce que effectivement je trouvais que
des fois mon
téléphoneand quand je décrochais il y
avait il y avait du fer ça raisonnait
donc plusieurs fois donc bon comme j'en
sais rien je suis allé voir puis je suis
pas parano de nature donc je l'ai j'ai
fait cette démarche il faut être parano
je sais sur surtout en ce moment ouais
donc est-ce qu'il y a des services à
l'Europe qui vous sensibilise sur le
tamponnage de puissance étrangère est-ce
queil y a des services de police ou
d'enquête qui peuvent vous aider à
éviter de vous faire siphonner
est-ce qu'il y a est-ce que vous êtes
protégé non clairement non mais oui oui
c'est mais c'est une vraie question mais
le problème c'est que si on on commence
à rentrer
là-dedans qui va organiser ça qui va
contrôler ça c'est une vraie question
parce que Madame Van derlayen a émis
cette hypothèse le problème c'est qu'on
sait que si c'est fait par la commission
c'est une comment dire on va déléguer
encore des compétences à la à la à la
Commission et aujourd'hui vu la tend
c'est peut-être pas forcément ce que
l'on souhaite moi je préférais
effectivement que ce service que ça soit
un service français qui s'en occupe pour
les Français et que chaque État membre
peut-être effectivement a cette cette
extension de pouvoir pour pour protéger
effectivement les députés français par
rapport à cette cette problématique mais
vous avez raison sur le fond et
aujourd'hui il y en a pas non il y a pas
du tout effectivement de mise en place
de d'un service qui pourrait en tout cas
nous alerter sur ce type de de
tamponnage euh moi c'est vrai que
pendant la crise covid sans être parano
je me suis dit euh bon Virginie tu vas
loin euh j'étais prudente parce que
c'est comme je l'ai dit c'est beaucoup
de milliards de dollars en jeu euh tu
peux quand même voilà contraindre ou en
tout cas mettre un peu des bâtons dans
les roues donc donc prudence mais voilà
prudence pourquoi parce que vous aviez
peur de finir entre quatre planches que
votre voiture explose que vous aez
problème de cap de frein de non mais il
y a eu savez il y a des des petites
alertes quel genre moi j'ai eu deux
petites alertes en 2023 quel genre
euh mes comptes bancaires du jour au
lendemain on les a supprimé
entre n les jours de l'an 2023 je reçois
une courrier de ma banque alors que ça
fait des années que je suis là c'est
jamais ri passé et là on on me clôture
mon compte et sueli de ma fille voilà et
ils sont c'était une erreur informatique
non terminé madame n na et donc j'ai dû
j'étais sans banque début dem ouais ça
et puis is c'est des petites alertes
c'était de fin 2023 et en même temps
était 2023 2023 c'était compliqué c'est
l'année c'était votre excusez-moi je
tombe des vous ou députés
européen on vous a sucré votre compte en
banque mais mais non et celui de votre
fille ouais les deux t de l'agence que
vous avez ouverte oui à l'époque depuis
20 ans j'étais sur dans la même banque
sans explication mais ils étaient très
désolé et au téléphone ils a dit c'est
pas nous c'est qui c'est pas nous elle
m'a dit pouvez pas aller plus loin B je
me suis dit c'est plus haut vous avez
les traces de ça B j'ai la lettre comme
quoi madame vous aime bien mais à partir
de temps vous êtes plus client chez nous
et donc j'ai dû chercher notre banque
donc ça c'est ma petite je me suis dit
sans être parano et puis en même temps
la même année je suis appelée par
l'ambassade des États-Unis qui me dit
vous devez rendre votre passeport on
vous enlève votre visa diplomatique ah
je me dis bon
ah ça vous vous dites plus rien et donc
j'ai rendu mon visa diplomatique parce
que normalement en tant que député
européen vous êtes amené à vous déplacer
et donc j'avais fait la démarche d'avoir
ce visa euh pour 5 ans pour le mon
mandat puisque j'étais allé à l'époque
pour la réglementation du DMA c'est
c'est le petit frère de du DSA digital
service que tout le monde connaît
maintenant et DMA c'est digital market
Act qui encadre les gars femmes
notamment pour lutter contre le monopole
des grands et donc on était allé à San
Francisco donc il y av pas de problème
mon visa marchait euh l'année d'après je
suis allée au CPAC à Orlando bahà aussi
j'ai utilisé mon visa il y avait pas de
problème et puis été 2023 je reçois un
email sur ma boîte du Parlement
ambassade des États-Unis vous êtes
convoqué à l'ambassade vous devez
ramener votre passeport moi je me dis
bon j'ai vu ou j'ai pas vu ce ce message
je me suis posé question puis après je
dis sais quoi j'y vais j'y suis allée je
rends mon passeport je dis c'est quoi le
problème qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui se
passe il me dit là je vois qu'il y a TR
trois bonhommes qui arrivent derrière il
prend mon passeport et puis je leur dis
je suis suis blacklisté et là qu'est-ce
que j'avais pas posé comme question non
non madame surtout pas pas on peut pas
vous répondre et donc ils m'ont pris mon
passport ils m'ont Canel m'ont annulé
mon mon visa et puis sans explication
voilà c'était parce que quoi vot votre
partie avec une banque russe votre
partie s'est fait financer par un
oligarque russe j'en sais rien à ce jour
je n'ai pas moi je me suis combien il y
a combien de s sur votre ticket d'avion
non
non je n'en sais rien mais c'était
quelle année redites-moi 2023 c'est une
année compliquée c'est l'année bah c'est
l'année où il y avait où c'était la fin
de la la commission spéciale covid c'est
l'année où où on a voté ou pas en faveur
de enfin en tout cas on n pas voté pour
ce rapport mais c'était c'était cette
année-là ouais 2023 donc ça a commencé
avec voilà le le retrait du visa à l'été
et pour finir l'année c'est plus plus de
compte en banque alors voilà peut-être
que c'est le hasard mais moi j'y crois
pas moi je pense que voilà j'étais
surveillé et je pense que le travail que
j'ai fait sur ce dossier euh a
gêné vous vous vous avez al le coût du
visa
le coup du visa ouais alorsors j'ai pas
refait de demande j'attends de voir a
vous en parlez ouais je crois que c'est
la première fois alors dans ces CASL
premier réflexe de français bon il
appelle la DGSI dit bon il faut qu'on
discute il m aré ça qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez moi j'appelle ou non j'ai pas
eu cette ce réflexe j'ai pas eu ce
réflex vous connaissez d'autres
parlementaires qui ont eu le même
problème que vous de votre parti ou
d'autres parties non non vous posiez des
micros au Parlement ou quoi ben non non
c'est plutôt eux qu'on pose alors trêve
de blague trve de blague c'est plutôt
eux qu'en pose à mon avis c'est pas moi
donc vous avez suivi l'affaire des
micros dans les structures au Parlement
vous avez suivi l'affire les Russes il y
a pas pas des micros enfin non il y a
pas de de je sais pas c'est vous qui
dites ça là d'accord vous avez suivi les
Russes qui se baladent avec des des
coffres de voiture chargés de tout ce
qu'il faut pour pouvoir écouter juste à
côté du Parlement mais ça blague ou
c'est c'est vrai non c'est pas une
blague ah ouais d'accord ouais non non
je suis pas courant non non c'est vrai
honnêtement il y y a il y a a les Russes
il sont fait toperper bon c'est la
méthode russe c'est qu'ils sont pas très
très finauxy ils sont maladent avec des
des coffres de bagnoles rempli de de
matériel pour pouvoir écouter tout ce
qu'il y a autour bon c'était peut-être
pour écouter les petits oiseaux hein euh
je vais demander à un de mes techniciens
de me retrouver ou à la communauté qui
est en direct avec retrouvver le le le
scandale des Russes qui se font chopés
avec le coffre rempli de de matos
d'accord pour continuer
ça là vous m'estomaquez avec le coup du
visa vous avez pas été voir les
autorités françaises pour leur dire je
suis inquiète j'ai mon compte en B qui
vient de sauter bon c'est peut-être un
bug informatique j'ai j'ai été appelé
convoqué alors c'était l'ambassade
américaine en France ou à Bruxelles non
à Bruxelles
ouais parce que j'ai eu mon mon visa
là-bas non je j'ai pas des gens bizarres
qui traînent autour de vous j'ai une
période où j'étais il y avait des gens
bizarres ouis qui en 2023 ouais j'ai
fait attention ouais des des des
invitations à des soirées ou des gens
d'un coup qui débarquent je suis avocat
ouais j'étais un peu prudente 2023 et
puis en plus c'est vrai que
alors événement aussi important c'est
quand même la mort de Michel Rivasi le
29 novembre donc là je me suis dit
bon sans sans remettre voilà je je
attention c'est on est d'accord je dis
pas que Mor naturel ou pas mort naturel
c'est ça qu'est-ce que vous
sous-entendez moi je je sous-entends pas
je dis c'est un concours de
circonstances de 2023 où je me suis dit
il se passe des choses dans ce Parlement
c'est-à-dire voilà le visa le T
euh du jour au lendemain moi j'ai vu
voilà madame rivasie partir la veille
est encore bien il me on me on me fait
sauter mes comptes fin
2023 je me dis voilà je c'est juste
comme ça je me suis fait mon petit je me
suis fait moi mon petit puzzle à moi je
dis pas que c'est la vér vérité je dis
pas que il s'est passé mais voilà je me
suis dit bon je dois gêner c'est ce que
je j'ai expliqué aussi à à mon entourage
parce que il y a des gens autour de moi
voilà je dois chercher un compte en
banque vite fait début 24 2024 ah il
faut expliquer mais c'est un concours de
circonstances qui est qui est curieux je
me dis peut-être un jour on en saura
plus bon euh et du coup le visa
maintenant on verra s'ils avaient raison
ou pas là je vais faire la demande
euh avevec la nouvelle administration
Trump vous appeller oui aussi on verra
vous parler de Trump vous voulez qu'on
continue sur les catargetes les
rouiagetes les Mar oui parce qu'il y a
sur sur le
gate comme vous dites bah des influence
étrangère des des des suspicions de
corruption parce que c'est ça hein c'est
on achète des députés et et et j'ai
trouvé qu'il y avait d'autres modalité
aussi d'acheter des députés je vous
donne un exemple euh vous AZ mis un
gigolo dans votre chambre d'hôtel
non non pas non non pas pas ça non je
des kilos de cocaïne comme Hunter Biden
euh non non ce qui est marrant c'est que
certains sont très malins pour avoir du
fric parce qu'ils sont vous savez en
politique hein c'est le
fric le pouvoir l'argent d'autes la
drogue hein donc ça va pas marcher plus
loin donc et donc il y en a un là qui
était pour moi voilà je je travaille pas
avec lui mais en tout cas je l'avais il
était président de la délégation Union
européenne USA radeslav sirkovski vous
dit rien là mais j'aime bien en tout cas
quand quand je vois quelque chose qui
qui qui me pose question je regarde à
tout tout le CV le parcours pour
comprendre un peu aussi la dynamique
c'est ce président qui était ces
délégation était très agressif très
agressif par rapport à la crise en
Ukraine en Russie on est tous des Russes
mais elle était très agressive dans
cette dans cette commission il faut les
comprendre aussi les Russes font se pr
du moins les Ukrainiens se prenent des
kilos sur la tête ensuite il répondent
c'est la guerre il y a des estropiers
partout des cadavres des cimetières
partout c'est ça
peut vous retourner un petit peu le l'
TR on est d'accord mais mais mais là
c'était dans dans un espèce d'entrrisme
qu'il faisait dans cette présidence de
cette délégation et
c'était sans commune mesure c'est
c'était vraiment c'était c'était lourd
dingue donc d'accord il faut qu'on fasse
les choses proprement qu'on fasse des
belles résolutions qu'on pense
effectivement à à ces problématiques
mais lui il avait cette particularité
d'être vraiment très offensif et quand
vous regardez son pédigré vous voyez
qu'il était candidat pour être président
à l'OTAN qu'après donc il est venu au
Parlement il ait présidé cette
délégation US Union européenne et moi ce
qui m'a choqué c'est que tous les ans
tous les ans il allait en Arabie
Saoudite se faire une conférence sur 2
jours pour je crois 150000 € al je me
suis et donc je me suis dit alors lui il
mieux que le catar gate parce que elle
la pauvre finalement elle avait 800000 €
sur 4 ans mais lui et c'était donc voilà
s'est pris chopé avec ses billets mais
lui finalement comment tu peux justifier
150000 € sur 2 jours tous les ans bah et
c'est peut-être quelqu'un de très
important très intelligent regardez
notre ancien président de la République
je crois qu'il il a des tarifs qui
s'avoisine à ça oui mais il est plus il
a plus de mandat lui il a un mandat de
député européen donc là aussi déclare ça
il déclare quand il alors comment vous
save comment vous savez que c'est s
parce que c'est sorti dans la presse
c'est sorti dans la presse et dans la
presse polonaise parce que c'est resté
qu'en Pologne et parce que c'était
cétait une presse carré cubique c'estàd
car c'està pr offici
sourc oui c'était une vraie presse et
d'ailleurs il y a eu un droit de réponse
de de ce monsieur il a fait un droit de
réponse pour dire que c'était une
itation officielle de l'Arabie Saoudite
et que du coup bah il assumé
complètement d'aller là-bas pour de
jours 150000 €. et bah alors bah et
alors il a un mandat de parlementaire
c'est qu'est-ce qu'il va vendre là-bas
il va vendre ses services donc c'est
c'est vrai que c'est c'est une vraie
question il était peut-être
Speer il a il a peut-être une très belle
rhéetorique
et il est peut-être connaisseur d'un
d'un domaine sans doute sans doute mais
ce qui est choquant c'est que euh
c'est pas proportionnel déjà comment
dire vous êtes pour pouvoir dire que
c'est pas proportionnel voy c'est pas
proportionnel bah oui bah je peut-être
pas pas pas je m'appelle pas Radoslav
Sikorski ça c'est sûr je suis pas
candidate à la présidence de l'OTAN et
aujourd'hui je suis pas ministre des
Affaires étrangères comme lui en Pologne
et effectivement c'est peut-être ça
qu'il a peut-être il a peut-être vendu
ça pour obtenir ses fonds il a rien
vendu du tout il s'est fait inviter pour
150000 € bon bref ça vous choque pas moi
je trouve ça choquant en même
temps bien sûr que ça me choque m déjà
150000 € pour 2 jours plus ouais euh ça
fait combien ça fait combien de dollars
à la seconde non mais vous me refaites
le coup
là mais en dollar c'est quoi bah c'est
100000 à l'époque ça dépend ça dépend de
l'année aussi hein du dollar hein parce
que à un moment donné il était il était
plus fort en terme de corruption vous
avez vu d'autres chose qui se passait à
l'Union européenne qui selon vous est
est interpellant et bizarre moi je vous
dis curvac le laboratoire on fait un
chèque de 80 millions d'euros en Cour
des comptes elle vous dit bah non ah oui
elle on pose la question est-ce que la
Commission puisque kururvac a déclaré
qu'il ferait rien qu'il qu'il feraient
pas de vaccin pour la covid qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de ces 80 est-ce qu'ils vont
les rendre à la commission ils disent
non non on va s'arranger on trouvera un
deal mais la commission vous 80 millions
d'euros elle vous dit non on fera un
deal avec
kururvacc un autre appel de marché non
on sait pas ils ont fait un avoir ouais
de 80 1 million d'euros ah bah s'ils ont
fait un avoir c'est bon oui mais un
avoir de quoi bilan comptable comment ça
non mais un avoir de quoi de goodies
d'ailleurs on a posé la question c'est
on a quoi en échange de 80 millions
d'euros je veux dire c'est notre rôle de
savoir où va l'argent que font-ils avec
l'argent 80 millions d'euros c'est pas
c'est pas 800 € qu'on arrive un peu
aller on peut dire ok on vous prête 800
on peut attendre 5 ans puis 800 à la fin
on peut dire bon laisse tomber mais là
c'est 80 millions d'euros on peut pas
ils peuvent pas avoir ce type de réponse
quand on l'a faite dans devant la Cour
Européenne des comptes la commiss c'est
même la cour européenne des comptes qui
contrôle aussi le budget a mis en avant
cette question nous et je me rappelle il
y avait même madameivasi qui était là
toutes les deux on est monté au créneau
parce que c'est choquant on ils peuvent
la Commission peut pas vous dire on est
en train de négocier pour peut-être
récupérer plus tard peut-être plus tard
80 millions d'euros donc oui pour moi ça
fait partie des des des des des des des
comment dire des pas de la corruption
mais en tout cas
d'une utilisation à mauvais ant de fonds
publics et peut-être ouais quand on
regarde après le dossier curvac quand je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure quand vous
regardez qui sont les les partenaires de
cette de C les fondateur de cette
société c'est le pays allemand et c'est
Bill Melinda
Gates et un petit pourcentage un petit
actionnaire qui a 10 % là-dedans donc
vous dites sont bien sous tout couture
ces gens
peut-être hein mais en tout cas c'est de
l'argent qui ne devrait être récupéré et
être utilisé pour d'autres domaines
est-ce que vous faites votre compte vos
vos comptes est-ce c'est vous vous
remplissez tout seul votre déclaration
d'impôt sur Internet ou ouais ouais
ouais vous avez déjà eu un adressement
fiscal vous vous laissez ce que vous
souhaitez non non non jamais est-ce que
vous avez eu des contacts avec
l'administration fiscale tout le temps à
chaque fois je leur dis de vérifier et
que s'il y a un problème il me contacte
parce que tous les ans ça change et que
il faut suivre vous un expert comptable
non vous devriez c'est très bien je
pense mais c'est vrai que tous les tous
les ans ça se complique parce qu'il
rajoute des des nouvelles lignes j'ai du
mal à suivre parce qu'effectivement
comme je l'ai dit des chiffr moi c'est
ça fait préempli non non il y a une
partie qui est pas préremplie parce que
comme on a des revenus européens il faut
rajouter des annexes et d'autres annexes
qui se croisent et c'est vrai
que je je c'est compliqué donc c'est
pour cette raison qu'à chaque fois je
leur dis tout est transparent parce
qu'en plus vous savez bien que nous
comme nous sommes exposés euh nous avons
l'obligation dans de nous faire
enregistrer sur le la auprès de la Haute
Autorité de la vie publique donc pour
être précis et par cohérence avec ce que
nous déclarons euh moi c'est ce que je
dis aux au fil que si vous voyez des
incohérences de toute façon ils ont le
lien direct aussi maintenant avec ma
nouvelle banque et toutes les banques
donc s'il y a des incohérences ils nous
appellent
et et on se on prend
rendez-vous autre question l'Union
européenne au milieu de de conflits
géopolitiques géostratégiques de guerre
économique de votre expérience quand
vous êtes à Bruxelles est-ce que ils
sont conscients que ça commence à
chauffer un petit peu que il faudrait un
peu se muscler en terme de renseignement
économique de
prospective de stratégie est-ce que vous
avez identifié une stratégie européenne
ou c'est une stratégie qui était à la
base démocrate Biden que les les
Européens ont suivi où est-ce qu'on a
notre intégrité stratégique
avec nos défenses européens notre
défense européenne nos objectifs
européens ou est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que c'est une cours d'école
où tout le monde se tire dans les jambes
par exemple les Allemands tirent sur les
Français avec le nucléaire les Français
doivent tirer à gauche à droite est-ce
que c'est une cours d'école chacun
chacun pour soi et Dieu pour tous ou
est-ce queil y a un courant porteur
européen de défense européenne avec on
fait front contre les Russes on fait
front contre les Américains là ils se
retrouvent tous un peu la le bec dans
l'eau parce qu'ils avaient pas vu venir
le coup de Trump et puis ils avaient pas
vu venir le coup des des taxes de Trump
ils avaient rien vu venir et donc ils
sont pas préparés ils sont toujours en
réaction symptomatique ils sont toujours
à toujours à courir derrière le train
comme un chien qui court derrière la
diligence donc est-ce que vous sentez
que ça se réveille un petit peu déjà
rien qu'avec les Français je vous ai dit
on narrivait pas à s'accorder donc
imaginez au niveau européen donc il n'y
a pas de stratégie une vision d'ensemble
c'est chacun pour soi je vais vous
donner un
exemple là nous avons un dossier vous me
parlez de la défense européenne c'est
beau sur le papier c'est beau que sur le
papier là on est en train de faire ce
fameux cette fameuse stratégie pour la
défense européenne nous avons un
document là maintenant sous les yeux en
marché intérieur parce que comme je vous
ai dit je suis membre de cette de cette
de cette commission et donc l'idée c'est
de mettre en place un marché de la
défense européenne pour l'industrie
européenne privilégier d'abord
l'industrie européenne et bon moi je
vais essayer de défendre l'industrie
française et donc c'est un document pour
jusqu'en 2027 mettre en place jusqu'à
100liard d'euros de de marché pour
privilégier ce marché européen de la
défense et bien l'exemple typique c'est
que celle qui suit ce dossier c'est une
polonaise du PPE et elle a déjà tout
remodifié la copie de la mission pour
privilégier bah les pays
transfrontaliers qui eux aura plus accès
à ce marché pour ouvrir ce marchalié
avec la Russie ouais donc les pays
baltes voilà bah ils sont un petit peu
dans la M oui mais bon on parle d'Europe
ou on parle on parle de solidarité entre
pays européens ou pas c'est ça un peu le
projet normalement deuxième exemple elle
intègre la Grande-Bretagne qui peut
récupérer des fonds européens pour pour
alimenter le marché de la défense non
mais je vous dis c'est n'importe quoi
après la Grande-Bretagne ils sont pas
brexités ben oui ils sont normalement
ils sont plus là donc c'est pour vous
dire que vous donnerz l'exemple typique
de pas de stratégie de pas de protection
de de de de cette de cette défense dite
européenne en tout cas pour faire
privilégier l'industrie européenne et
suivi un peu les agérances Britanniques
au sein de l'Union européenne ou pas du
tout non non j'ai pas suivi j'ai pas
suivi j'ai pas V suivi les ingérences
russes au sein de l'Union européenne
em moi les seules ingérences pardon je
vais vous dire les seules ingérences que
j'ai jusqu'à présent c'est des
ingérences américaines désolé hein quand
on voit tout avant avant Trump je ne
peux pas vous laisser dire
ça je ne peux pas avant Trump les
Américains sont nos alliés oui mais nos
partenaires nos frères d'Ar on est on
est d'accord mais pour pour pour pour
leurs intérêts ça c'est sûr pour
défendre d'abord leur steak plutôt que
pour nous pour nous aider nous en tout
cas à défendre le nôtre et donc moi
c'est plus ça que j'ai vu jusqu'à
présent c'estàd que un autre exemple je
suis en délégation UE USA avec ce fameux
polonais et durant durant la durant la
la la commission que nous avions avec en
audition Washington parce qu'on est en
direct avec le bureau de Washington et
bien vous avez l'ambassadeur qui nous
représente là-bas à Washington qui nous
dit écoutez durant le conflit avec
Taïwan arrêtez d'acheter vos microchip
en Chine mais faites un traité pour
négocier directement avec Taïwan voilà
ils nous disent ce qu'on doit faire ça
c'est un exemple un autre exemple en ce
moment maintenant nouvelle
administration effectivement ils sont en
panique ils sont en panique à Parlement
au Parlement moi d'ailleurs si je vais
j'ai pris comme goodies très modestement
moi c'est des mouchoirs donc je vais
leur donner parce qu'ils ont ils vont
pasant 4 ans ils vont pleurer parce que
effectivement il faut qu'il s'y fasse à
Trump ils peuvent pas faire peuvent pas
faire 100 et donc là j'ai appris que
dans la nouvelle délégation je n figure
plus parce que quand j'avais vu ça à
l'époque j'ai dis bon j'arrête parce que
c'est vraiment me faire du mal d'aller
dans cette délg tion donc je n'y suis
plus mais j'ai un collègue qui a repris
le le le dossier et qui est membre de
cette délégation et là aujourd'hui
réunion à H clos alors que ça il y avait
pas avant wiclos ça veut dire on laisse
son téléphone dehors on doit rien dire
de ce qui se passe on doit signer une
décharge donc ça veut dire qu'ils
veulent vraiment protéger ce qui se dit
maintenant dans ces dans ces délégations
et donc ils sont atterrés c'estàd que là
ils savent pas comment s'adresser euh à
leur homologu maintenant qu' sont à
Washington ils sont même en train de se
dire est-ce qu'on fait pas revenir notre
ancienne homologue ici euh euh dans
l'Union à Bruxelles parce qu'ils ont
plus de contact euh aux États-Unis pour
eux ils ont plus de contact ils sont en
train de même réfléchir de remettre en
en en euh en comment dire euh en ordre
euh de de de de contact les anciens
démocrates enfin les démocrates actuels
parce qu'il veut pas parler avec les
républicains euh et et et donc ça pardon
donc donc pour vous dire aujourd'hui
l'énergie qu'il y a dans l'Union
européenne donc pas de vision euh pas de
vision éclatement des s intérêts chacun
défend sa poire par rapport à
l'administration Trump qui qui elle est
offensive pour le coup là effectivement
il va falloir que nous même français là
on soit on soit coopérant c'estàdire que
qu'on qu'on soit pas fermé mais en tout
cas il va falloir dialoguer il va
falloir protéger nos intérêts et bien
effectivement Union européenne làf en
tout cas Bruxelles d'avant et
d'aujourd'hui est en train de de de
de de montrer que elle est pas qu'elle a
aucune stratégie et qu'elle est très
faible très très faible vous avez bien
vu van derlen elle est en retrait on ne
la voit plus euh
elle est elle est pas elle un mal en
point euh elle a été très malade
d'ailleurs elle a été très très malade
euh on la voit pas vraiment revenir sur
la scène ces commissaires ils sont très
faibles excusez-moi mais le note le
français euh monsieur séjourné il a été
là encore de nouveau ça ça stratégie sur
le nucléaire a été remise en question
donc donc Bruxelles est très fa fibrile
mais c'est pas la faute de Trump elle
était déjà fébrile avant Trump euh deux
questions j'aimerais qu'on parle du
discours de Vance vice- président des
éats-unis et je voudrais aussi qu'on
parle qu'on revienne sur le fait que ils
ont pas de contact avec les les
républicains c'estàdire le parti de
Trump c'est que vous m'avez expliqué que
ils sont son en panique parce qu'ils
savent plus à quel homologue est-ce que
vous avez pas l'impression que l'Union
européenne en fait c'était une extension
du Parti démocrate américain exactement
ouais tout à fait je vous donne un autre
exemple la semaine prochaine délégation
IMCO donc c'est la mienne marché
intérieur mais j'y suis pas là puceque
j'ai fait l'autre il retourne à
Washington pour parler du DSA du ddma
donc de toute la législation du
numérique je viens d'apprendre que en
fait ils vont aller là-bas et ils ont
ils vont pas avoir de rendez-vous avec
le gouvernement Trump donc pourquoi y
aller j'ai envie de dire c'est quand
même la base mais comment mais parce
qu'ils ont pas les contacts et et en
plus ils on pas les contacts c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible regardez
nous on est capable de faire venir le
l'ambassadeur iranien donc c'est très
simple je vous explique comment on fait
on prend le téléphone on regarde sur
internet ambassade d'Iran on fait 36 15
bonjour d'accord on tombe sur une
gentille dame ou un gentil monsieur on
lui dit on souhaitera avoir une une une
interview de l'ambassadeur là comme à
chaque fois dans toutes les ambassades
que soit l'ambassade de Suède
l'ambassade des États-Unis de Russie
d'Israël de tout n'importe quelle
ambassade c'est à chaque fois la même
d'ailleurs c'est très rigolo ils vous
disent écrivez-nous un petit mail main
hier et là on leur dit bon nous on
nécrit pas de mail on souhaiterait
parler à quelqu'un alors là ça dépend de
la puissance que vous avez en face ils
vous disent désolé pour on donne des
recettes de
cuisine on leur dit nous nous on a 1,3
million d'abonnés sur Youtube alors là
on leur provoque un laence connaissez le
réflex de lawence c'est quand vous
avalez votre sal vous nettoyez vos
lunettes parce que vous sentez qu'en
face il y a 1 million de personnes c'est
c'est quand même faut y aller faut y
aller donc là à chaque fois on nous
passe le responsable médiia presse ou de
de contact la majure partie du temps les
ambassadeurs leur conseill nous
connaissent parce qu'il regarde nos
émissions et là on commence à discuter
et on voit et on a un contact
et vous vous êtes pas capable de faire
ça al c'est pas moi c'est le secrétariat
IMCO qui a essayé apparemment de joindre
cette plateforme pour leur arrivée à
Washington et moi c'est ce qu'ils m'ont
dit et d'ailleurs ça a été communiqué
officiellement alors vous avez raison
c'est facile normalement la question
c'est est-ce qu'il y a pas une un manque
de volonté aussi de les rencontrer et
c'est plus grave parce qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui on peut pas se couper du
fait qu'il va falloir travailler avec
eux et c'est vous voyez encore les
choses de travers je vous dirais
regardez mais c'est pas ça c'est
peut-être que les Américains ont pas
envie de leur parler ah bah ça parce que
ils considèrent l'Europe comme non
légitime et que le gouvernement Trump
préfère discuter de puissance souveraine
à puissance souveraine ça c'est votre
supposition non c'est un autre angle
d'attaque oui c'est c'est aussi on peut
aussi l'entendre mais euh mais mais
c'est effectivement c'est une
problématique qui a été déjà aussi vu
euh là dans cette commission avec la les
USA et l'Union européenne où ils ont
cette problématique qui sa savent pas
comment parce que le problème qui se
pose c'est que ceux qui sont présidents
de cette délégation c'est un renew donc
Macron et socialiste et je pense que
c'est ils l'ont pas dit officiellement
mais c'est eux qui refusent là pour le
coup de prendre contact donc là c'est
ridicule et c'est pour cette raison que
nous on se propose finalement d'y aller
parce que ils nous ont mis le cordon
sanitaire on a accès ils ont pas voulu
qu'on ait accès à ces présidents et
vice-présidence ironiquement on leur a
dit bah si vous voulez pas y aller nous
on y va mais mais oui c'est c'est une
vraie question et je pense que dans la
stratégie
soi-disantque diplomatique et de
réindustrialisation puis c'est ce qu'on
il nous mett à toutes les sauces là on
va on va se redevenir plus fort mais bon
un moment donné voilà il y a cette
réalité et et vous m'avez posé la
question par rapport au discours de J
devans et je reviens là-dessus c'est
important merci
oui je suis quand même je suis pas bonne
en math mais je
j'écoute je retiens
on fait on fait on fait ça alors ça
énerve de temps en temps nos auditeurs
ouais mais c'est en fait pour mettre une
petite pression d'accord gentille sur
nos invités non non mais je suis à
l'aise ça va non je reviens parce que
c'est important ce discours moi j'ai
beaucoup apprécié et raisonne dans le
travail que moi je vois depuis un moment
et que je suis il y a eu la période
covid on a vu et je parle des vaccins
mais pour moi je l'ai vu encore avec
plus d'utr de manière encore plus avec
une notre vision de vue pour moi c'était
voilà je comme vous avez dit c'est c'est
mon mon appréciation avec une espèce de
face test notre capacité à nous
soumettre à un truc complètement dingue
la volonté de mettre en place ce
passeport d'identité numérique en même
temps voilà je l'ai suivi aussi ce
dossier donc je sais pourquoi c'était
relié après la pandémie et euh et et et
j'écoute maintenant depuis depuis que
j'ai découvert le livre great reset là
je connaissais pas du tout ce monsieur
Claus Schwab m'intéresse au Dav conna
pas du tout ce ce ce livre non je
connaissais pas même Claus Schwab mais
je me suis intéressée à à lui depuis que
dans la durant la crise covid je me
quand je lisais les posts tout le monde
me disait oui c'est le Gret riset je
sais pas ce que c'était donc je me suis
renseigné donc j'ai découvert que tous
les ans il y avait ce fameux sommet de
Davos pourquoi je reviens aussi haut
parce qu'il y a 2 ans Madame Van der
layen avait fait ce fameux discours
d'introduction elle fait toujours ce
pour introduire Davos et elle avait dit
que durant les deux prochaines années
euh la priorité c'était pas de lutter
contre le changement climatique c'était
pas les pandémies c'était pas la crise
en Ukraine mais c'était de lutter contre
la désinformation et là je me dis
punaise c'est pourquoi et là elle
continue dans son discours dit oui parce
que ça sera de années d'élection voilà
et ça c'était pour moi je l'ai gardé
j'ai gardé la vidéo je me suis dit ça à
un moment donné ça va nous servir et en
fait elle n'
vous savez comme ils sont d'avos ils
font des plans sur 10 années 20 ans 30
ans ils écrivent tout enfin leur
stratégie comment enfin et du coup en
fait bah oui c'est quand on voit
maintenant après un an on a compris un
peu l'énergie on a compris ce qui
mettait en place parce que vous avez dit
effectivement manque de visibilité
euh l'Union effectivement s' frrite mais
elle s' frite par rapport à quoi en fait
surtout par rapport au résultats des
élections c'estd que depuis 2 ans on a
vu ce ce nouveau cycle qui s'est mis en
place ouais mais vous pouvez pas nier
qu' il y a des puissances qui ont essayé
de retourner des éctionû alors attendez
je je vais il l'ont fait d'une façon il
ah bah il y a la Russie qui a machin il
y a le Maroc il y a machin il y a les
Roumains non il y
a tout le monde tout le monde essaie de
retourner les révolutions de couleur le
oui mais là c'est quand là depuis 2 ans
quand même toutes ces élections elles
sont cadrées c'est quand même pas
n'importe quoi le nov choc à gauche le
machin à droite
non 2 ans on a quand même des faits on a
du factuel en 2 ans il y a eu une série
d'élections 2024 a été une élection en
faveur des patriotes faut faut être
honnête c'est-à-dire que vous avez cette
vague qui était là depuis un moment
d'ailleurs nous on fait partie de cette
vague là pour ça que depuis depuis 2019
bon on a le vent poupe de 25 de 20 % on
est passé à 30 là aux derniers élections
sanitaire a l'air de fonctionner euh au
sein du Parlement mais c'est pas
terrible he il va il tient pas trop
parce qu'il y a quand même des des
victoires et donc du coup bah vous avez
toutes ces échances électorales qui ont
qui qui malgré toutes ces ONG qui sont
qui font un travail de SAP et puis aussi
de sensibilisation de SAP moi je dirais
de campagne de dénigrement on vous ferme
les compte en banque on fait des procès
on fait on met la pression c'est quand
même une réalité pour nous notre parti
politique qui votre fiche Wikipédia
exactement vous avez vu elle est belle
he elle est magnifique moi moi je je
l'ffiche au bureau il peuvent écrire ce
qu'il VE veulent durant la campagne vous
avez essayé de tracer les IP pour
l'avocat c'est très intéressant non j'ai
pas essayé on a essayé plusieurs fois de
demander à rectifier et puis après j'ai
abandonné écoutez peu importe toute
façon dire que votre parti de temps en
temps il prête le flan ouais mais bon
euh les assistants parlementaires oui
benah alors ça aussi on pourra en parler
mais ça prendrait des jours les
qu'est-ce qu'on reproche aux assistants
parlementaires on reproche finalement
d'avoir travaillé pour un parti
politique un parti politique c'est pas
une entreprise comment vous arrivez à
définir la la la la la la comment dire
euh le le les comment dire l'activité
d'un assistant euh de 8h à 11h je
travaille pour mon député et puis de de
11h à à à 11h30 ce député qui a aussi
une casquette de présidente de parti et
bien il faut quoi il faut se déconnecter
faut rebatg là parce que pendant une
demi-heure non c'està dire qu'en plus
assistant moi j'entendrais un assistant
fictif si cette personne euh n'était pas
en train de travailler c'estàdire que au
lieu de travailler 9h elle serait au
club ou en Thaïlande là oui c'est du
fictif mais là là ces gens ont vraiment
travaillé ouais ben ben c'est c'est
c'est clou c'est pas le cled hein donc
très sympa saintclou ouais mais mais
donc c'est pour dire que il y a il y a
et puis sur les assistants fictifs on
sait très bien que que c'est c'est pour
moi c'est un procès politique euh
certains ont réussi à négocier ce
dossier onentend plus parler aujourd'hui
alors que d'autres parties ont toujours
parce que c'était une pratique des
partis politiques c'est dire que
l'assistant travaille pour un député il
travaille ce député travaille pour un
parti donc l'assistant lui il fait pas
la déconnexion à savoir à un moment
donné quand vous avez une association
qui appelle elle demande pas est-ce que
vous voulez lui parler en tant que
député ou en tant que présidente du
parti vous voyez c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est donc pour moi euh un un un sujet
qui est détourné toujours pour dénigrer
et toujours pour nous mettre des bâtons
dans les roues pourquoi parce
qu'effectivement euh même si euh euh la
presse fait son travail de SAP et bien
vous avez quand même un engouement son
travail d'enquête
pourquoi pas fait il y a quand même un
engouement il y a quand même une partie
de la population qui ne tombe pas dans
le panneau et qui continue à voter pour
nous je prends notre exemple mais aussi
bah dans toute l'Europe c'est dire qu'il
y a un réveil de ces énergies de des
patriotes pour en tout cas défendre les
intérêts de chaque euh identité de
chaque chaque État membre et et se
réveil et là depuis un moment déjà
depuis 2019 avec vous nous on a réussi à
mettre en place ce groupe politique
identité déémocratie nous étions 60 75
on était descendu à 50 et là maintenant
on est presque 90 parce qu'effectivement
90 sans lad puisqu'on est plus avec la
FD aujourd'hui ils ont leev en poupe et
juste ça c'est parce que vous avez
bénéficié des campagnes d'astrurfing de
puissance étrangère qui énervaent les
peuples c'est pour
ça moi je l'ai pas vu he sur le marché
hein quand je donnais mon tracte aux
gens ils m'ont pas dit oui alors j'ai
reçu un coup téléphone de Russie il faut
que je vote pour vous moi je l'ai pas vu
hein non c'était peut-être un coup de
fil d'ailleurs
hein ils ont peut-être compris qu'il
fallait arrêter d'appeler depuis la
Russie ah ben je sais pas ou alors un
tout enfin ou des Américains ou
peut-être je sais pas dans trêve de
plaisanterie quand bon on ça fait un
certain nombre de mois qu'on vous
surveille ouais qu'on surveille votre
boulot qu'on vous regarde sur vos
réseaux sociaux qu'on écoute vos
interventions parce que notre communauté
du moins une partie de notre communauté
nous a demandé de faire de la veille sur
ce que vous racontiez ouais donc on a
écouté on a écouté on a écouté ensuite
on vous a envoyé un ça va c'était pas
trop dur non c'est intéressant qu'on
soit d'accord ou pas d'accord on sait
reconnaître les gens quand ils
travaillent qu'on soit d'accord avec ou
pas avec
vous on peut pas vous enlever le fait
que vous bossiez d'une façon passionnée
ouais c'est
vrai bon on vous a envoyé un message sur
Twitter comme vous bossez comme une
tarée vous avez mis des mois à nous
répondre c'est voilà c'est vrai que
et mais vous avez quand même répondu
donc pour c'est pas moi pour le coup
c'est un de mes assistants il m'a dit
j'ai dit oui j'ai voilà j'ai pas fait
att il y a certains députés européens
ouais permettez-moi l'expression on les
voit pas beaucoup de certains partis
politiques dont le vôtre les jetons de
présence on les voit pas beaucoup vous
avez des noms je sais pas vous avez un
nom en tête non pas du tout pas du tout
non non parce que donc est-ce qu'il y a
des des des faux des putés européens qui
n'ont que le titre ou qui ne travaillent
pas parce que on reconnaît les gens qui
ont les yeux fatigués il y en a certains
qui se mettent des lunettes pour passer
à la télé et qui se laissent pousser la
barbe de 3 jours pour dire qu'ils sont
fatigués mais entre gens qui travaille
on se reconnaît à la taille des cernes
là vous avez triché je le sais tu voyez
non du coup ça non j'ai mis de l'antier
bien sûr on se reconnaît parce que pour
manger les travaux de de Virginie non je
travaille très vite non c'est vrai
j'arrive j'ai cette capacité est-ce
qu'il y a pas des faux débutés du Moi
débutés qui qui en fait qui n'ont que le
titre et qui ne sont jamais
là-bas je peux pas
je ils sont connectés par la pens non
c'est pas ça c'est que c'est que c'est
difficile à de se comparer avec des
autres parce que peut-être c'est
difficile de critiquer son chef de parti
non c'est pas ça c'est que je encore une
fois c'est comme la la question
précédente euh c'est pas parce que il
est pas à un moment donné à une
commission qu'il ne fait pas le taf il
est pas là il est il est quand par
exemple il est pas dans cette commission
à ce moment précis non non c'est pas
parce qu'il a il est en train de de
fumer un cigare à Cuba vous voyez ce que
je veux dire il travaille ailleurs donc
Cuba ah Cuba j'aimerais bien aller à
Cuba mais après si après je être encore
blacklisté donc vous me faites une belle
diversion et vous avez bien saisi
comment faire vos diversions avec moi
quand vous partez dans un certain pays
qui être potentiellement dangereux mais
pour vos vos vacances par exemple Cuba
ou par exemple la Corée du Nord ou par
exemple un autre pays est-ce que vous
prévenez à nos propres services que bah
ce serait bien qu'il viennent vous
chercher s'il y a un problème non vous
êt vraiment imprudente ouais et en plus
j'adore les pays compliqués donc je suis
très non je crois ma bonne étoile j'y
vais on
verra non non je suis pas pourquoi je
vous savez peut-être je suis trop humble
mais moi je pourquoi les les embêté ils
ont d'autres choses à faire que dire là
Virginie Martine va à tel endroit
qu'est-ce qu's en a à faire ils ontre
chos à faire non non non vraiment je
veux pas les embêter ils ont d'autres
sujets plus intéressants que de savoir
que que Martine est partie au Pakistan
non non enfin moi je je je je me sens
pas aussi importante pour les embêter
vous totalement inconsciente parce que
ça si on vous enlève ça va coûter un un
bras une députée européenne on va pas
m'enlever quand même bon revenons
euh qui font pas grandchose et qui ben
ça c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
parce que
peut-être il a il y a pas assez de
visibilité sur ses travaux mais non mais
très très honnêtement euh et et puis moi
croisez souvent non tous les à chaque
fin chaque plinière il est là après moi
c'est vrai que on n' pas les mêmes
commissions il y a 27 commissions
différentes non c'est vrai il y a 27
commissions différentes euh donc il y a
des gens que je vois jamais et c'est
vrai mais par contre ils sont dans leur
commission on le découvre sur Internet
qu'ils ont été en Agri on n' pas les
mêmes on n' pas les mêmes agendas déjà
c'est la première des choses et puis moi
j'ai ma seule responsabilité moi là là
Virginie Jeon c'est mon mandat de député
européen je n'ai pas d'autres
casquettees donc je dois être à fond sur
ce mandat vous êtes pas dans la
commission sur les les ingérences
étrangères alors ça s'appelle commission
Bouclier européen pour la démocratie et
ça on va en parler parce comment ça se
dit en anglais shield for
Democracy European shield for Democracy
perfect
ACC joking non mais c'est important
parce que on a raté le fil sur la
Roumanie les élections c'est très
important parce que pourquoi parce que
quand vous voyez juste une question ici
c'est c'est moi qui tient les gens de la
commission qui siègent à la commission
ils ont eu un petit pédigré de nos
services européens pour savoir s'ils
étaient pas dans ont certains groupes
secret d'ingérance payé par certaines
puissances du Commonwealth ou de la
Russie vous pensez à qui je pense à
personne je vous pose la question par
rapport à cette commission normalement
ils doivent chaque député qui se
présente à une présidence je vais donner
par exemple madame
l'oiseau pour cette commission doit
transmettre son sa déclaration de de de
bonne conduite je crois s'appelle comme
ça à vérifier bon c'est un nom comme ça
mais c'est officiel et c'est sur son
site elle l'a fait elle l'a fait et donc
on a appris c'est là que j'ai appris
qu'elle était membre de ce fingan qui
s'appelle European Concil for foreign
affair et alors for foreign relation et
alors français ça donne quoi c'est c'est
conseil européens pour les relations
étrangères ok c'est
pas et on a appris en regardant parce
que moi je suis curieuse en fait c'est
ça aussi elle a le droit d'être dans un
S tank si elle veut des contacts pour
aller ensuite défendre le de l'Europe
aux États-Unis il faut qu'elle ait un
minimum de réseau B c'est pour ça qu' il
y a pas de problème si après c'est pas
pour nous faire a pas touché deessous de
du S tank bah j'en sais rien en tout cas
elle est membre de cette de ce F tank et
c'est vrai que dans le travail que moi
je fais peut-être plus que d'autres
c'est que j'aime bien comme vous avez
dit vérifier ce que c'est ou regarder ce
que c'est moi je suis curieuse donc je
vais voir comme vous voyez tout travers
et ben oui ben oui mais je vois
tellement tout travers que quand je
regarde ce que c'est je vois que que il
y a d'autres députés qui sont membres
comme la Luc comme Van brand qui est
aussi membre de cette commission alors
après je dis oh bah tiens mais qu'est-ce
que c'est que ce truc qui finance quoi
donc je regarde qui c'est qui paye ah
ben je vois Soros je vois B bind Gates
et alors bah et alors ben on nous parle
on nous on nous ennuie tous les jours
qu'il faut se protéger des interférences
ou des influences
étrangère Soros il est pas français hein
euh Bill Gates non plus donc si on dit
je faut faut être un minimum cohérent si
on dit qu'on veut lutter contre toute
ingérence ben on lutte contre toute
ingérence et pas celle qui nous plaisent
donc c'est ça moi c'est quo les
ingérences qui nous plaisent et ben ben
moi en tout cas il y en a aucune qui me
plaise moi je suis indépendante moi je
suis pas dans un f tank je suis je suis
juste au parti du rassemblement national
et dans ce de groupe des patriotes mais
moi moi je suis vraiment indépendante et
quand on on voit que des gens en plus
vous avez dit faut pas diffamer mais
quand même je vous permettez qu-ce que
je vous ai dit avant le direct j'ai dit
pas diffamé
dénigrementig pas de diffamation si vous
avez des chiffres sourcés car cubiqu
voilà alors là je vais quand même ouvrir
cette parenthèse mais madame l'iseau
pardonnez-moi
euh est-ce que vous souvenez qu'elle a
fait campagne pour les européennes non
est-ce que vous avez souvenir de son
premier bilan de son premier mandat non
je réponds pour vous hein pardonnez-moi
est-ce
que le travail a été couronné de succès
par rapport à son premier mandat non
carisme de Madame l'oiseau non mais le
charisme ça c'est pas grave pourquoi
Monsieur Emmanuel non mais pourquoi
Emmanuel Macron l'a reconduite sur cette
liste parce qu'elle est peut-être plus
efficace sur d'autres dossiers que vous
maîtrisez pas euh qui se souvient d'un
dossier qu'elle a suivi au premier
mandatah sur l'Ukraine elle défend
l'Ukraine B c'est pas un dossier et
c'est pas elle c'est la c'est c'est
c'est Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs il l'a pas invité là quand il
reçu tous les chefs d'État non elle est
pas chef d'État oui mais bon vous dites
que il a reconduite parce que parce
qu'elle était bonne sur le sujet et elle
maîtrise ce sujet alors le seul la seule
alors la seule fois où je la vois je
vais être dur la seule fois où je la
vois vraiment s'agiter hein elle a pas
fait campagne durant les élections
européennes he moi je me rappelle pas
l'avoir vu faire campagne durant les
élections européennes pourtant c'était
il y a 6 mois par contre elle fait
campagne en Géorgie alors là j'ai jamais
vu autant sur le marché en geéorgie
parce qu'elle conteste les élections le
rés des élections je reviens là-dessus
parce que c'est important ce qui se
passe ce cette commission bouclier pour
pour la démocratie donc déjà ils sont
mis en mode défense un bouclier ça veut
dire oh là là on se fait attaquer contre
les c'est pas le cas on se fait emmerder
par les Américains oui mais pour eux
c'est les Russes ils ont pris exemple
depuis un certain nombre d'années ouais
mais là aussi c'est quel exemple les
marocquains le Pégasus les machins ah
mais il alors vous avez dit il faut être
précis moi je je suis comme vous je veux
vous avez pas l'impression que l'Union
européenne c'est un peu ouvert au cas
vant que chacun peut faire sa propagande
les lobbyistes d'un tel d' industriel de
il y a les puissances qui se baladent
ouais mais là on qui tamponnent qui
tamponnent les gens qui leur offre des
goodies donc ils sont mis en mode
défense alors bon ils ont toujours pas
compris qu'il fallait se mettre en mode
attaque se mettre en mode défense ils
ont essayer les attaques mais ils ont
confié ça à des gens qui étaient pas
formés pour ou du moins qui s'estimaient
formmer pour mais ils se mettent en mode
défense c'est normal regardez dans
l'état où est l'Union européenne à
gauche on on a un front et à droite on a
un autre front mais défense par rapport
à sud on a un front
ouais mais pour en revenir à au fait que
c'est une défense par rapport à la
démocratie et donc c'est une défense par
rapport au résultats des élections d'où
ce discours de JD V qui est très
important parce que qu'est-ce qu'il a
dit il faut pas lutter qui c'est pas
l'extérieur c'est pas chercher midi à 14
la Chine les les États-Unis qui sont
problématiques c'est à l'intérieur le
problème et ce qui est le problème ce
qui est remis en question notre
démocratie c'est parce que les résultats
électoraux leur posent problème et donc
aujourd'hui se mettent en défense par
rapport à ces résultats électoraux c'est
pour ça que je vous parlais des
résultats qui a eu précédemment nos
résultats les résultats le vent patriote
qui s'est mis dans toute l'Europe que ça
soit au Pays-Bas avec guvilders le Vlams
bang en Belgique en Autriche le FPO
demain laafd en Allemagne donc tout ce
vent de panique qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
pris en pleine face et surtout le pire
donc le cyclone qui les a ébranlé c'est
Trump parce queeffectivement depuis
cette claque qui sont pris arrivent pas
à s'en remettre voilà se sont sont pris
fait
COG son sont pris ça dans la tronche et
depuis ils s'en remettent pas ils sont à
terre et alors pour comme ils sont pour
eux c'est une attaque donc bouclier le
bouclier pour lutter contre ces attaques
qui sont pas à l'autre bout du monde qui
sont ici et d'où cette d'où cette
effectivement ces scandales que qu' l'on
voit tous les jours parce qu'on est en
train avec Us aide c'est-à-dire c'est la
boîte de Pandor où on voit que tout ce
système qui a été mis en place depuis
des années par les démocrates qui est
donc qui est donc venu ici pourrir
acheter euh avec tout t tous ces F tank
ces ONG qui sont pourris jusqu'à la
moelle parce qu'elles défendent ouais
c'est mon interprétation parce qu'il
lutte contre nous il lutte contre
finalement la liberté d'expression il
lutte contre le notre nos intérêt parce
que il nous empêche finalement de
défendre nos intérêts je reprends
l'exemple du marché européen de la
défense c'est un exemple typique il nous
empêche de défendre de protéger notre
défense nationale donc finalement c'est
vrai que cette dynamique qui qui vient
de qui vient depuis des années enfin
cette année en terme d'élection avec des
résultats qui leur font la peur et c'est
pour ça que cette mise en place de cette
commission est pour moi intéressante et
je suis je me suis battu pour rentrer
dans cette commission et suivre ce qui
va se passer parce que pour moi on vous
en avez juste parlé parler là de la
Roumanie mais ce ce dossier de la
Roumanie c'est une pépite c'est une
pépite pourquoi parce que c'est
l'exemple type du cas qui veulent
répliquer pour les prochaines élections
c'est du flan là vous me parlez
d'ingérence en Russie il y a pas
d'ingérence quand vous regardez le
dossier c'est pour ça je suis désolé
j'ai j'ai j'ai regardé j'ai lu j'ai
c'est ce que je vous ai dit avant le
direct je dis moi je cogne et vous
ouvrez les portes
voà quand quand je je vous chambre c'est
pour vous donner le temps de répondre et
d'écouter vos ouais non mais c'est dans
le sens où où euh j'ai pas pu regarder
toutes les émissions c'est pour dire que
j'ai pas eu le temps parce que j'avais
viginom qui était là lundi en audition
viginom c'estàdire c'est le nouveau
service relié au au Premier ministre qui
concerne un petit peu font des enquêtes
sur euh les c'est un service de l'État
qui est nouveau pour qui enquête sur
toutes les les les ingérences étrangères
et donc ils ont fait une enquête sur les
élections en Roumanie et dans ce rapport
14 pages je l'ai lu deux fois et j'ai
pas trouvé mais même pas le début d'une
preuve qu' a une ingérence russe déjà pr
il est écrit en gr je lui ai dit à
Monsieur Brant que j'ai eu lundi qui
était voilà il a fait son taf je lui ai
dit je lu dis mais vous dites bien que
attention en gras la surreprésentation
dans les médias ou même dans un dans une
pleine forme ne finalement ne ne présume
pas que peut-être ça va donner le
résultat escompté quand il y a musk qui
dit il faut voter l'extrême droite
allemande ouais voilà il a combien de
followers musk il en a beaucoup plus de
200 plus de 200 millions ouais mais et
puis et puis et puis quand même c'est un
sacré crédit quand c'est li de c'est un
peu comme Barack Obama qui dit qu'il
faut voter Macron ouais bon ça a marché
là non et alors on aurait dû annuler les
élections c'est ça la question est-ce
que est-ce que c'est ça ma question
est-ce que quur Swift où nous nos Marion
contillard et compagnie il appellent à
voter quelqu'un euh est-ce que est-ce
que est-ce que c'est parce que ça va
influer ou pas cette parole simplement
leur parole bah oui mais la parole je
suis d'accord avec vous on est juriste
ou pas juriste c'est dire que le message
et la vidéo est-ce que ça implique
forcément le bulletin de vote dans
l'urne je Madame Michu qui tranquille
Madame Michu c'est c'est c'est c'est ma
grand-mère
elle est là elle est sur son marché elle
a peut-être regardé un tweet de de de
Taylor Swift à l'époque ù elle a
peut-être plus libération appelé à voter
Macron alors revient sur les plateformes
parce que c'est ça la problématique non
il faut pas que je m'égare je reste sur
les plateforme elle entend le message
d'on musk qui qui n'a pas qui dit qu'il
soutiendrait
laafd c'est son message euh ok elle va
peut-être voir le tweet mais c'est pas
ça ça veut pas dire qu'elle va voter
pour le message qu'elle aura lu et c'est
ça le le qu' va il va falloir se battre
et moi je je tiens à le faire dans cette
commission c'est dire que ce lien
juridique cette preuve parce qu'on est
là on est des juristes la preuve
tangible entre le message et le bulletin
il va falloir me le montrer sauf que la
preuve l'enquête le temps de l'enquête
l'étude de sur combien de Madame Michu
ça provoque l'acte de vote ça prend du
temps et là les élections bah c'est Val
j'ai posé la question il a été incapable
de répondre a dit oui c'est vrai on on n
pas le lien on peut pas faire et on peut
pas faire le lien matériel ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'on on va mettre des
des capteurs dans le cerveau de Madame
Michu quand elle vote pour voir ça fait
bien le lien avec le message c'est
impossible donc pour estce que vous
rappz de Cambridge Analytica ouais c'est
quoi Cambridge mais c'est aussi une
campagne de ciblage publicitaire qui a
été faite durant les élections de Trump
pour pousser notamment une certaine
population à voter Trump cétait financé
par
qui c'était pas c'était pas des
Britanniques je réponds pas aux question
ici mais mais alors un intéressant quand
ce cas parce qu'effectivement ils ont
utilisé dis quand je dis ils ont la
Commission à utiliser ce
cas pour mettre en œuvre une
réglementation du ciblage publicitaire
pour encadrer les partis politiques
j'étais d'ailleurs dans ce dossier pour
que les partis
politiques puissent communiquer sur les
campagne publicitaire parce
qu'effectivement bah ciblage politique
ciblage publicitaire qu'est-ce divance
euh euh qu'on était nul si finalement on
annulait des élections par rapport à des
interférences bon il a dit beaucoup
chalement il a dit trivialement votre
système démocratique est sacrément
faible voilà parce que si si les Russes
avec une des centaines de milliers de
dollars achète de la pub si votre
système n'est pas suffisamment robuste
pour encaisser ça bah c'est qu'il y a un
problème c'est qu' a un problème mais
moi je voulais pas rentrer quel heure
est votre train euh à
18h 17
mais juste pour finir parce que c'est
intéressant ça ce ce ce sujet parce
qu'on va le on va le revoir il faut être
très enfin en tout cas moi je suis très
prudente de la lecture de la commission
par rapport au DSA on en a pas parlé
digital service Act pourquoi parce que
le texte il est pas il est pas il est
pas mal hein pour ça que on me critique
toujours les mêmes pourquoi je me suis
abstenu parce que ce texte à la base il
a été rédigé pour encadrer les gar femme
suite à la fermeture du compte de Trump
par rapport à quand c'était Jack Dorset
et donc on voulait un peu un cadrer
parce qu'on s'est dit attends les gars
du jour au lendemain parce que c'est
Trump on lui coupe le sifflet donc on
s'est dit pourquoi pas il faut encadrer
ils peuvent pas faire n'importe quoi
c'est pas le Far West et pour lutter
contre les contenus illicites pour
lutter contre les réseaux
pédopornographi pour lutter contre les
produits défectueux qui viennent de
l'autre bout de la planèt les les chin
temu et tout et donc le texte éétait ça
à la base et il y a un article et
pourquoi j'en parle parce qu'on en a
parlé lundi soir dans cette fameuse
audition un article c'est qui est la
mise réaction aux crises mesure de
réaction aux crisees donc on utilise cet
article il est précis donc pourquoi pas
couper le sifflet de d'une plateforme
numérique que que si il y a un du
terrorisme conflit armée ou pandémie
tris cas il y a pas élection d'accord
donc donc c'est important parce que dans
la Commission dans laquelle j'étais
lundi la question de la présidence de la
commission était détournée à la
Commission je m'explique il madame
l'oiseau par son intermédiaire lu en
voulez hein non mais parce que j'aime
pas qu'on nous prenne pour des idiots et
et et et donc elle pose la question à la
commission commission qui s'occupe de la
mise en œuvre du DSA elle lui dit oui
vous avez donc l'article 36 pour la les
mesures de de réaction aux crisees et
donc notamment comme par exemple lors
des élections lors des élections pour le
contre les ingérences c'est pas ça dans
le texte il y a pas écrit ça et ce qui
est bien c'est que la Commission pourquo
vous vouavez pas marqué c'est pourquoi
pourquoi ça pas été marqué dans le texte
je vous prends un figure je vous prends
un figure vous avez des agents Dormand
genre the Americans
ouais des agents dormants ouais des
influenceurs
dormants contrôlés par des puissances
étrangères alors que leurs services
internes ne les ont pas vu et là tout à
coup il y a une élection ils se
réveillent tous et ils disent votez tous
pour Monsieur Michu h il faut pouvoir
réagir du tac au
tac
ben vous vous avez peur que ce soit
détourné non moi je je je je je je crois
euh je crois au au au au aux gens quoi
moi je pense que les gens sont pas assez
stupides pour faire ce que ce qu'on leur
dit quoi je veux dire les gens ça fait
des des mois et des mois qui connaissent
leurs candidats qui ont reçu leur tracte
qui regardent la télévision qui voient
les débats je je enfin ça veut dire que
on fait pas confiance aux électeurs qu'
qu'on les croit si stupides donc on il
faut les protéger en en limitant l'accès
à l'information alors si si si on vous
suit ben on fait la même chose avec la
presse ok quand libération dit à appeler
Emmanuel Macron bah alors il faut il
faut le supprimer ou on fait quoi là ça
veut dire charte de Munich pour ça bah
oui mais en tout cas lors des élections
ils font ce qu'ils veulent et on le voit
bien surtout au second tour il y a il y
a il y a il y a il y a qu'un narratif
c'est tous contre nous et on se
débrouille on va dire mais alors si si
on applique cette parce que moi je suis
quand même pour la diversité je suis
pour la liberté d'expression et pas que
moi même notre parti politique
aujourd'hui voyez c'est quand même
d'actualité de de de de dénoncer
aujourd'hui le lynchage contre même si
moi je regarde pas la télé C8 et Energie
12 je ça veut dire quoi ben c'est aussi
ça ça fait partie on peut le raccrocher
à au discours de Jid Vance on est en
train il a dit n'ayez pas peur à la fin
n'ayez pas peur il a dit au vieux
système en place là qui voit que tout
c'est en train de s'effriter ils sont en
train de perdre à chaque élection ils
perdent des des sièges et c'est ça la
trouille et donc ils on ils perdent du
pouvoir moi je renew premier mandat dans
2019 ils étaient 23 ils se retrouvent à
13 ah bah ouais ils ont 10 sièges de
moins et puis au prochain j'espère
qu'ils seront encore encore moins mais
c'est ça la trouille et donc c'est pas
c'est pas protéger la démocratie c'est
pas protéger les gens en fait moi je
l'entends vous dites ouais ingérance les
pauvres et tout là on va je me fais
l'avocat du diable oui bah moi je fais
l'avocat adverse je donc du coup
protéger les gens de quoi en fait à bien
voter mais qu'est-ce que c'est bien
voter en fait on les empêche d'aller
vers le candidat qu'il souhait et c'est
ça que moi c'est c'est comme le covid il
a un truc c'est pas possible il faut les
gens sont pas assez stupides pour pour
se faire pour croire qu'ils sont aussi
influençables vous avez suivi le dossier
qui s'appelle les Twitter files ouais
c'est quoi euh
alors il y avait Biden dedans il y avait
le covid et c'est Helen musk bah c'était
suite à son rachat de X qu'il a
découvert qui avait des narratifs il y
avait des interductions faites à X à
l'époque Twitter de censurer et av du
Shadow banning il y avait de la censure
il av il avait de censure il y avait
l'affaire Biden le fils Biden peut-êre
des services de renseignement américains
qui faisaent remonter des noms pour
pouvoir faire taire certaines certaines
personnes est-ce que vous avez légiféré
pour éviter que ça se
reproduise est-ce que vous comprenez
aussi peut-être que le camp républicain
garde
une un goût amère des twit sur les
Twitter files et qu'il il a peut-être
essayé de dire à l'Europe que
méfiez-vous nous ça nous est arrivé
c'est compliqué par rapport au discours
de javance bien sûr je pense que je
pense ben c'est ce qu'il a dit ce qu'ils
ont vécu eux et ils ont réussi à à à
outrepasser toutes ces embuches et c'est
vrai qu'il nous qui nous alerte qu'il
faut pas suivre le même chemin et qu'il
faut respecter il le dit aussi tous les
partis même si on les aime pas ça fait
partie de la de la protection des
valeurs et on a les mêmes valeurs de
lutte pour notre démocratie et c'est
vrai que ce discours je l'ai encore relu
avant de venir en diagonale parce que
voilà il faut lire aussi le rapport sur
les ONG qui est en train de sor qui est
sorti et qui est très intéressant il
faut que je le publie il faut que je
l'analyse parce qu'il y a plein de
chiffres sur toutes ces ONG qui ont pris
de la gent alors vous avez US aide mais
là vous avez carrément des fonds
européens des fonds européens qui qui
ont permis d'alimenter des réseaux d'ONG
et et notamment là quand cette
commission bouclier de lundi vous avez
des experts qui ont été donc appelés par
cette commission expert forum donc de
Roumanie et on s'est rendu compte qu'ils
été payé par Soros voilà et ça voilà
donc ça il y av pas eu une commission
d'ailleurs c'est c'est un de vos députés
qui était Président de de ça si je me
trompe pas en France sur les ingérences
étrangères il y a eu ça en France non
est-ce que les gens qui ont été
auditionnés ont eu un pédigré regardé à
la loupe pour savoir si par exemple ils
étaient pas dans un groupe x secret
cétait à l'assemé nationale je éé qui a
été financé par le Common Wells ou la
Lituanie ou les États-Unis et qui aurait
touché des sous pour un contreenarratif
X ou Y mais en fait ils auraient
instrumentalisé le truc il y a pas eu ça
si oui non pas souvenir non pour revenir
à Nathalie
l'oiseau c'est peut-être normal qu'elle
s'inquiète on a une économie qui est
compliquée les perspective économique
sont compliqué on a un front à gauche un
front à droite un front au sud elle se
dit peut-être que c'est le dernier
rempart face à la montée des extrêmes et
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'elle essaie
de faire des boucliers et elle essaye
essayer de défendre pendant 2 minutes
Nathalie
l'oiseau défendre son steak quoi après
c'est sûr mais c'est pas ça la
démocratie c'est pas ça les valeurs de
de la de la République liberté liberté
égalité fraternité il faut qu'elle
respecte le choix des électeurs c'est
pas moi qui a fait la loi c'est pas moi
qui fait oui mais bon il faut aussi ce
sont aussi les mêmes valeurs de l'Union
européenne le respect de la démocratie
de la liberté d'expression elle a
peut-être peur que il y ait un nouveau
fascisme en Europe mais oui mais parce
que regardez l'économie à chaque fois
que ça ça Calanche qu'est-ce qui arrive
au pouvoir
compliqué je je je je vois pas je vois
pas l'exemple là en fait conflit
géopolitique augmentation des tensions
haine elle a peut-être peur que il y ait
dans 3 ans un parti qui émerge de nulle
part financé par une puissance
étrangère qui Vienne un démon en Europe
voilà on va la rassurer Nathalie
looiseau la pauvre la pauvre dame non je
pense que il faut plutôt qu'ell se
remettent en question qu'ils analysent
leur bilan qui est nul et c'est pas
notre faute si les gens veulent plus les
voir ils veulent passer à autre chose je
veux dire faut pas arrêter de se
chercher des ennemis ou des peurs il
faut juste se regarder faire son analyse
de de de de son travail et si les gens
parce que c'est pas moi si les gens ne
veulent plus voter pour eux c'est pour
une bonne raison c'est qu'ils ont
constaté qu'ils avaient plus leur place
ils l'ont donné leur chance de de de
gouverner de travailler de faire des
choses et qu'aujourd'hui bah le résultat
n'est pas bon donc il faut qu'elle
laisse sa place aux autres question
internet que pense-t-elle du parti
allemand AFD comment se positionne le RN
et ses différentes tendances internes
par rapport à eux alors moi j'ai très
bon rapport avec l'AFD et d'autres
collègues aussi d'ailleurs Christine
Anderson j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec
elle durant la crise covid euh voilà il
y a eu à un moment
donné une petite crise parce que au sein
de ce parti il y avait des personnalité
qui ne correspondait pas à à à notre
ligne et et Alice veidel voilà elle a eu
elle elle a reçu ses critiques elle a
fait un peu du nettoyage dans son parti
parcece que céit aussi un jeune parti
avec des fois des des problématiques de
personnalité et elle a fait le le
nettoyage mais bon voilà on a des bons
rapports je je suis contente pour eux
qu'ils soi aussi haut dans les sondages
j'espère qu'ils vont encore augmenter
qu'ils vont tenir et euh boulevard là
non euh oui bien sûr mais pour ils ont
un boulevard et ben parce que paraî par
rapport aux mêmes arguments que je viens
de vous dire c'est-à-dire déjà le bilan
des socialiste en place en
plus Madame Merkel qui avait ouverte la
porte à toute cette immigration
aujourd'hui tous les jour il y a des il
y a des actes de terrorisme il y a pas
longtemps encore une attaque à muniich
donc ce qui constate eux ben enfin le
diagnosti qu'ils avaient posé il y a
quelques années il le constateent encore
plus que nous donc donc c'est pour cette
raison qu' ils ont ses résultats assez
haut et et en plus peut-être du travail
à venir avec les les conservateurs qui
vont devoir faire avec on verra ça
dimanche hein les résultats sont
dimanche ce qui est ce qui est plutôt
pas mal c'est qu'on a quand même ils ont
compris parce qu'à un moment donné il
était dit il était question peut-être
d'annuler les élection attention c'est
pas encore fini hein c'est quand même un
épisode àreandissement quand vous avez
tiré breton il y a quelques temps qui a
dit alors là aussi l'oiseau elle m'a
elle nous a attaqué parce qu'on a on lui
a remis dans on lui a remis ça dans la
tête lundi on lui a dit on lui a dit
attention quand vous avez un ex Un
ex-commissaire qui s'exprime sur les
plateaux pour dire que s'ils appliquent
pas bien les règles et bien on est là
commment on l'a fait en Roumanie on le
refera nécessaire en Allemagne elle nous
a dit que c'était de la désinformation
c'est quand même fort de café et donc on
voit bien que que cette envie vraiment
envie de certains députés de
d'annuler la plateforme durant la
période de campagne électorale était
vraiment poussée par certains députés
lundi soir nous avions quand même on est
quand même en période électorale un
porte-parole allemand concernant le
bureau des élections qui est venu nous
donner un petit peu son point de vue
donc là aussi est-ce que est-ce que
c'est un point de vue effectivement pour
lutter contre contre la désinformation
et les ingérences donc on est en pleine
campagne électorale moi je dis c'est pas
très correct d'inviter un porte-parole
allemand pour pour parler des élections
alors qu'on est en période électorale
normalement devrait avoir une certaine
neutralité et on verra dimanche les
résultats mais mais mais j'espère qu'on
a en tout cas
euh sauvé ces élections dans un sens
parce que il était question à un moment
donné pour certains d'annuler les
élections et on verra dimanche en
fonction des résultats parce que Breton
quand même il l'a annoncé est-ce que
vous connaissez les réseaux Gladio non
est-ce que vous connaissez euh
l'activation de certains terroristes
pour faire des attentats en Italie il y
a très très longtemps ça vous parle pas
non renseignignez-vous sur ça à mon avis
pourquoi pourquoi on pose cette question
c'est c'est en terme de manipulation
électorale avant il faisait ça à la dure
oui mais après une autre il y a d'autres
façons aussi de euh
de comment dire de de de s'ingérer dans
les élections question internet pardon
oui allez-y non non vas-y question
internet il a-t-il du nettoyage à faire
également au sein du
RN alors là euh je je je sais pas je non
je crois pas non je parce qu'il y a sans
doute une question derrière encore plus
plus pointu mais bon moi pour le coup
non et si vous dites qu'à la FD ils ont
fait le ménage lui ah oui c'est par
rapport à ça ben non le ménage a été
fait depuis longtemps euh est-ce qu'il y
a un sujet que vous souhaiteriez aborder
très rapidement parce que je vous je je
veux pas que vous loupiez votre train on
a tout fait on a fait le plus important
on a pas tout fait il on a encore mais
des T de
questionsir je
revienne j' tellement de choses à vous
dire oui on a pas eu le temps de dire
l'Agence du Médicament européen on
parlait de scandale je le fais vite bon
ça fait partie de toutes ces cet argent
qu'on utilise lise comme ça c'est pas
notre comme les contrats c'est pas notre
argent donc on dépense on met n'importe
quoi une petite anecdote je pense qu'en
France on a pas assez parlé l'Agence du
Médicament européen qu'est-ce qu'elle a
après le brexit euh elle s'est rendu
compte qu'elle avait un immeuble à
Londres
euh et qu'elle est engagée jusqu'en
2039 pas de clause de résiliation donc
aujourd'hui on paye 30 millions d'euros
pour se pour conserver enfin pour
conserver parce que on s'est engagé que
la Commission a mis quelqu'un une
société à a sous-traité la a sousloué
son bâtiment manque de bol est vraiment
elle a pas de chance la société est en
faillite donc ils arrivent pas à
récupérer l'argent manque de bol ils
sont obligés de payer plus d'un million
3 de cabinet d'avocat pour essayer de se
dessaisir de du building à Londres et en
parallèle ils ont construit un un
immeuble au Pays-Bas pour cette fameuse
agence du médicament européen 300
millions de dollars
pour la construction de ce building et
tous les mois faut que j'aille vérifier
parce quand j'ai vu chifr je me suis
c'est pas possible 13,5 million d'euros
par mois de location voilà donc voyez un
petit c'est un exemple pour vous dire
même si c'est pas de la corruption même
si c'est pas et encore on peut se poser
la question parce que le l'immeuble de
Londres où on est engagé jusqu'en
2039 le propriétaire de cet immeuble
c'est c'est un fond souverain cataris
c'est quoi la marque de votre montre
Rolex oh ça paye bien je peux vous
raconter l'histoire elle est très belle
c'est un cadeau oui
de de mon premier fiancé j'avais 17 ans
ah ouais il me l'a offert parce qu'il me
quittait ah ou et et et pai à son âme il
est décédé 2 ans après d'un accident de
moto donc je l'ai depuis l'âge de 17 ans
bonne réponse est-ce que vous êtes pour
la création de Dodge un Dodge à
l'européenne j'ai répond qu'est-ce que
c'est Dodge c'est le département de pour
un gouverne un gouvernement efficace et
je pense qu'il faut la même chose
c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qu'on fait bah
comme je l'ai dit un immeuble comme ça
hop en sucre toutes ces dépenses comme
si c'était l'argent pas notre argent on
arrête toutes question internet question
internet si la prochaine fois il faut
repartir le lendemain matin si la FD
passe et sort de l'Union européenne quel
pourrait être les
impacts que ça pourrait avoir sur la
France bon alors déjà moi je ris impact
ça aurait sur la France déjà step by
step déjà attendons les résultats
dimanche soir ils vont être très haut à
voir s'ils arrivent à faire une
coalition avec la CDU parce que tout
seul ils peuvent pas et après cette
question elle sera elle sera poser au
aux Allemands vous êtes pour le frxit
non est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté premier
moi il a c'est lui qui m'a ouvert
presque le 3è si on peut appeler ça 3è
c'est le livre de Serge Alimi LES
NOUVEAUX CHIENS DE GARDE 97 c'était
voilà j'ai appris là c'est là que j'ai
c'est à partir de là que je regardais
les les médias d' d'une autre façon
euh je l'ai dit tout à l'heure parce que
j'aime beaucoup Socrate et c'est le
j'aime bien Frédéric Loir parce que la
politique les rapports les chiffres tout
ça à un moment donné j'aime bien me
sourcer ailleurs voir d'autres choses et
d'avoir trouver le sens de tout ça parce
que c'est un sens il faut avoir Mo il
faut que ça un sens donc le livre de
Frédéric Lenoir c'est Socrate Boudha
Jésus c'est maître de vie voilà c'est
c'est pour moi c'est c'est c'est
important je trois mais je pourrais en
dire plus j'auris tous les livres qui
concernent la crise covid euh donc celui
de Christine coton celui d'Alexandra
Arion code celui de Pierre Chaillot
celui de Christian
Peron j'en oublie pardonnez-moi si S me
regarde mais tous ceux qui ont écrit
parce que je trouve que chaque chaque
personne personnalité a amené une pierre
au cel édifice pour comprendre cette
cette pandémie pas dit des
bêtises je sais pas je je je je lis je
me fais moi ma propre opinion je sais
pas s'ils ont dit des bêtises mais c'est
intéressant parce que chacun a apporté
sa petite pierre à l'édifice que ça soit
pierre Chaillot par rapport au
statistiques que ça soit alexandrecodet
par rapport au vaccin RN messager
Christian Peron pour nous expliquer le
virus j'ai pas lu celui de Didier raultl
mais voilà pour moi sont c'est important
parce que c'est une période euh qui pour
moi euh est importante vous avez vous
allez louper votre train oui et le
dernier vous avez dit je moi je finirai
par quand même le Great reset un conseil
pour les jeunes générations quelque
chose d'impérissable une bouteille à la
mer sur
internet de faire de faire ce qu'ils ont
envie de de faire déjà esprit critique
de toujours aller de toujours la période
covid pour moi est une période
importante euh c'est euh toujours
remettre en question
quelque chose qui ne vous convient pas
que vous sentez qu'il y a il y a une
problématique donc en tant que moi je
l'ai dit à ma fille hein elle avait 15
ans à l'époque je lui dit tu vois ça
c'est la meilleure expérience toujours
vérifier comprendre pourquoi tu on te
donne ce type de de de de de comment
dire de de décision l'esprit critique
euh vérifier recouper les informations
et faire vraiment ce qu'on a envie de
faire quoi Virginie Jauron merci merci à
vous
[Musique]